oh my God
that's all I have to say so we have this
guest uh we have a spreadsheet that
shows all the guests who are coming on
the show that explains like contact
information pick up points travel
details and this Monday on the list it
just said oh my God and that was the
week before because we were planning on
doing this show with yay Fuentes and uh
Milo
if you didn't see it I'm sure most of
you did uh they broke the internet with
Alex Jones today where Kanye wearing a
Balenciaga mask gloves with a bottle of
Yoo-hoo and Annette was imitating
Netanyahu with a high-pitched voice he
went on to do to say that uh he was a
Nazi Kanye said that he he loved he said
he loved them right is that what he said
he defended he defended Hitler
he denied the he denied I want to be
very very careful about this elements of
the Holocaust and then uh I don't I
don't even know I mean we'll pull up a
bunch of these clips we'll talk about it
he he called me an NPC he made up some
fake story about me getting a phone call
before the show which is just not true
I'll give you all the details exactly
about what happened because it's more
like it's like close to what was true
but not what happened and
um Mike zernovich tweeted that Tim Poole
dodged a bullet I don't even know man
this is so it's it's weird how is this
real life so I guess we'll talk about it
but um we do have this head over to
timcast.com we put up the Green Room
episode with yay West Green Room number
35 you can find it in the members only
section this is a mini dock it's 23
minutes long showing the the crew my
brother he went out met up with them
they fly back what happens when they get
here things like the limo didn't show up
they dip off to matsutaki Hibachi and in
Frederick what was happening with fans
yay standing around talking with us the
things that were said the things he was
doing it's all there wanted to show
everybody uh what happened it's just
very strange
um the way things played out but it's
available there green room number 35 is
up you can become a member to support
our work smash the like button subscribe
to this channel share the show all of
that good stuff we got a whole lot to
talk about because it's just it's just a
very very crazy day I'll put it that way
and joining us to discuss this and so
much more is Alex Stein a pip on a blimp
eating steak and shrimp oh my gosh I get
to be here Tim had we went in there like
a very nice Orchard talking about that
you know insane incident but let me just
start off by saying this you know
because I know everybody else in here is
a regular but
um you know I got a few Christmas gifts
and I know you know this was probably
one of the most legendary rappers
that you could ever meet right and you
know Kanye West and I think and
everybody should be proud but now that
you guys are mortal enemies here's your
newspaper
Tupac yeah
so there you go here's the two box for
you that's a good one I got YouTube Park
and we got see and I got Ian because
Ian's like the uh you know uh smoker
smoker 420 Vibes it kind of looks like
him a little bit yeah we got the sublime
but you look disappointed is that
disappointing no I love you a lot you
like Sublime it looks like him I think
it's a large but if you dry it enough
it'll shrink it's a brown I'm excited
I'm kind of anxious
I got you the same two-part yeah but
listen okay then then but then we got
another thing and if you don't like
Tupac
got Lil Wayne himself
skateboards he's cool and again he's got
skateboard kid Lil Wayne so now we got
that and then and then look at this and
then I know this is not probably the
proper uh nomenclature but they didn't
have
loose all right Lucas so it's not the
same it's not necessarily the same and I
hope this doesn't dox us no no no you're
fine it's actually spelled with the seat
little way on a little skateboard there
we go this is nice I'm gonna change into
the sublime shirt I'll be right back and
then and then I also got this uh okay
okay here so we'll go
Thomas J this is black Thomas Jefferson
oh you're the black Thomas Jefferson all
right gotta open my mind from Hamilton
yeah he was attacking him Vibes so there
we go and then nice and then for me I
just brought this just because you guys
always have your own decoration and I
know
I just kind of wanna this is just for me
I want to leave this year just because
this is BTS for the people playing at
home a lot of you guys don't know good
music especially you I mean I know you
have like the hit song but this is
actually they're arguably the greatest
artists of all time so I would I would
actually start really listening to your
music if you had more of a BTS Vibe boy
band
if we could join up and do this and in
rip Nick Fuentes
I bet the chat's Mad okay here let me
just put this up and then we can go back
to the show I apologize all right so now
you know who Alex Stein is if you don't
yeah so on the grind all the time what
an intro what an intro uh Luke is here
so uh we we got a crazy man for a crazy
day my name is Lou kardowski here of we
are change.org today I'm wearing my make
taxation theft again shirt as the IRS is
reminding everyone that they have to
report every single transaction over 600
on PayPal as the Pentagon just lost
another 2.2 trillion dollars they don't
know where it went they don't know where
I found it this is why I know what
happened last time last time what
happened let's not get into it
September 10th 2000 all right all right
the best if you want the shirt if you're
if you're disgruntled at the IRS you
could get it on the best
politicalshirts.com because you do
that's why I'm here I'm happy to be here
Alex thank you so much for the gifts oh
look at this shirt what a huge Sublime
okay and you got to try it a couple
times but it does shrink it's Walmart
they they played out here Sublime with
Rome I think they played here like a
couple once a month or so ago Bradley
Knowles the original the OG shout out
love you guys love the dog what's the
dog's name the dalmatian blue dog Blue
Dog shout out to Lou dog we also got
Serge pressing the buttons what's up
guys what an intro right oh and search
because you know I have to say this
Serge I forgot search his name because I
just met him earlier it looks I hear a
Serge you can get uh transgender Whitney
Houston because you're the new
transgender Whitney Houston nice you
know Lydia yeah transition I know you're
a good man you're a human being man with
male genitals but good voice execution
is in between so it's all about
transition so you guys the new Legend
you guys ready hell he's good yeah let's
jump in we're just going for it here's
the story from timcast.com I'm just
going to let you guys know I'm not
reading a single quote from this man yay
yay calls Hitler a cool leader and makes
other anti-semitic comments during
Infowars appearance you can't say that
out loud that's what yay was saying he
was doing the was it Mussolini made the
trains run on time thing that whole bit
yeah that whole argument it's just let
me just play I'm gonna play Clips I
gotta I gotta play this clip because I
just it's just crazy so let's let's is
the audio good I like Hitler I like
Hitler
give me that I'm not trying to be
shocking I like Hitler I do not I the
the Holocaust is not what happened let's
look at the facts of that and Hitler has
a lot of redeeming qualities oh my God I
understand he's trying to do the
Christian forgiveness Arc of like
everybody has Humanity in them and it's
coming out wrong it's coming out blunt
and people aren't gonna unders I don't
think people are understanding I don't I
don't think that's what he's doing Ian
at all let me let me play another clip
for you you know it's like he had a
really cool outfit and stuff and he was
a really good architect and uh and so
you're in love with the with the with
the with the arc the the look of it and
he didn't kill six million Jews that's
just like factually incorrect guys get
the Ronald Reagan clip they show me
interesting sorry go ahead Ronald Reagan
said that too well I think Hitler did
Target and kill some people
Obama kill Palestinians I don't I I Alex
that was I don't know man come on Alex
why is why is he just said are you
talking about Alex Jones
Alex Jones sorry Alex Alex Jones being
like I think he did Target and kill some
people like I I don't know like this may
be a bit personal but I think Luke had
family members who were personally
targeted by that yeah yeah my you know
family died
we're not Jewish we weren't Jewish but
my great-grandmother ended up in the
shutoff concentration camps my great
grandfather on my mother's and father's
side died Fighting the War uh we still
don't know if it was the Russians or the
the Nazis but obviously the Nazis
provoked that situation in Poland so
yeah I mean I had a lot of family
members pass away uh from from you know
a lot of crazy stuff throughout you know
polish history but I don't want to be
using that as as a way to just say I'm
offended because you know obviously
these are in in yeah insane comments but
I don't want to use my family's history
to add to the insanity of today I want
to go like I just want to make this
point though because when I saw that
clip I said on YouTube tube and then a
recommended video is Norm McDonald
talking about Adolf Hitler joking about
it and you know he said it first you
know the more you look into Adolf Hitler
you know the less I seem to like him and
uh you know I just I just can't imagine
that like
Kanye did some research oh you know what
oh actually he uh he designed the
Porsche he's good he made it
he said he invented the microphone yeah
I mean true yeah yeah I mean it's like
you know I
it's never a good look to idolize or say
anything possible Adolf Hitler is so
obvious I don't know why he's doing that
it's not just shocking I think he's
seriously confused or under some sort of
hypnosis uh I wanted to address you know
you said insane and this is a part of
Megan earlier
he I think he's extremely wrong Hitler
didn't invent the microphone maybe
there's some like there maybe maybe he's
expressing whatever ideas trying to
express incorrectly I think he said he
invented the microphone that I use and
he was like Serge pointed out he's is a
piece of technology in the microphone
that lets you hear vibration close to
the throat so tank commanders could use
them uh well it's like the the tank mics
in World War II were like on the throw
and that's something they did invent
it's not I don't know what he's saying
that's the only thing I could think of
watching is like maybe is that what he's
talking about but yeah I don't so I just
want to say there's a difference between
being crazy because everyone's saying
he's having a psychotic break and I'm
like okay first of all he does that
thing he pulls out a net and a Yoo-hoo
bottle and he's like net and Yoo-hoo or
whatever and he's going like we're gonna
come take your kids and I'm like that's
that's performative like if I saw
someone doing a weird show on the street
so I wouldn't say they're crazy I'd be
like like a performer is doing a
performance if he believes things that
are are just you know grossly incorrect
or he's expressing them incorrectly or
he's praising people that are very bad
that to me is not a sign of mental
illness it's a sign of a person who is
wrong about a thing right and at any
time
I just want to make one point here
because many times he was also just
going to Nick and didn't have the
answers and you could see he was kind of
filling in a lot of blanks here but he
wasn't even you know he was talking
about also about Planned Parenthood and
he's trying to equate different things
to different scenarios but if he really
would have understood the situation he
would have understood that Margaret
Sanger the founder of Planned Parenthood
was a big American eugenicist that
inspired the Nazis that inspired you
know Hitler with his larger uh Final
Solution Eugenics depopulation control
agenda that he implemented so if he's
really against all that stuff he would
have obviously seen the parallels here
so I I don't know some people are saying
he's just trying to be controversial
some people are saying he's crazy some
people are saying he's just filled with
hate uh whatever whatever it is
everyone's talking about it I just want
to point out who knows exactly why
because there's a very few people that
there's documentaries where they say
that there's some evil cabal that is
ruining the world and that Hitler was
supposedly stomping that out and that's
why they in his head he thinks that that
was a good thing yeah but when you look
at it that's what he thinks it is
happening and that's what some people
think out there and I want to break that
that's incorrect that's just as I
understand that's what he thinks yeah
but then it was Prescott Bush the
Rockefellers and it's not one and a lot
of group of people a lot of our bigger
Industries especially in the United
States that was financing Germany
um and you know there's also you know
the Soros thing the Arnold
Schwarzenegger thing operation paper
clip there's a lot of things that
intertwine here that that show us that
obviously there's something bigger here
historically but but he's not bringing
that up he's bringing up a lot of things
to try to provoke people to try to get
some kind of emotion out of people to
try to get people angry to try to get
them stirred up here what's the reason
what do you guys think Alex Jones said I
know you're trying to be shocking he
says no no I'm not yeah he
I don't know man uh just what's the
reason why is he doing it because
obviously he's he's Kanye doing that
yeah
it's personal I mean some things it's
just something happened to him you know
by losing his bank account and I don't
know if that he was on the edge because
you know when you get you're trying to
say it's not mental illness Tim but you
can get like in these hyper focused
rabbit holes because I don't know what
do you guys think he drinks is he on
drugs and I'm not saying I have no idea
and I know I know for I'm pretty sure
Nick or my I don't know if they use
drugs but I'm pretty sure they don't he
said on the show that at some point he
found himself drinking and like you know
having orgies and then he realized like
he shouldn't be drinking because the
king shouldn't drink or something like
that and so then he stopped so he
doesn't drink like when he tweeted he
said when he tweeted the death con thing
he was drinking and he was drunk oh he
was and then he said because the Bible
says you can drink but the Bible says
the king shouldn't drink and then I
realized I shouldn't well his mental
health is never going to get back
together so you think it's mental health
or do you think he's trying to spread
hate or do you think he's legitimate
crazy or what's the solution because it
seems like you're saying and crazy I
mean I think it's a little bit of both I
mean you know they say that that like
you know a lot of these School shooters
happen everybody's like oh what's on the
FBI's radar this and that you can get
radicalized by the stuff you see in your
search engine and your algorithm by the
stuff that you've repeatedly watched and
the stuff that you're trying but you
don't see this stuff what what uh yay is
saying every photo I see of him he's on
his phone he's on his phone and I'm a
guy that's addicted to my phone because
I do stuff my phone I had a little clip
sometimes and it's a film something that
I'm always on my phone and so I know
what it's like to live in there so I'm
sure he's always in a rabbit hole he's
always on a plane he's like what oh my
gosh when he was here we were talking to
him he was on his phone the whole time
and we were having a conversation then
he just kept this is a black you know
this guys this is a Black Mirror when
you look at this phone guys look at this
this is an evil device this is what
basically the transhumanist agenda like
this is it has an apple on the back of
it that's happening for a reason
I know it's anecdotal to say that
because it's also anecdotal to say
there's fluoride in the water but yet
you use ice at every restaurant yada
yada like it's just still though this
guys and I'm addicted to it so I am the
biggest hypocrite it's terrible for your
brain
you're pointing out the SIM the the
symbolism of an apple like the Garden of
Eden and the Apple that was in is bitten
and then yeah yeah I got the vibe that
Kanye was or yeah was uh just totally
mentally broken and totally but mentally
broken when they took his bank account
down like he realized oh even if I have
500 million tomorrow they can snap a
finger and it goes to zero or something
they got money you still got money he's
got hundreds of millions he said I think
that was like a black pill and now he's
like thrashing around trying to figure
out what to do and he's gone full Christ
Consciousness he's like I'm gonna be in
full forgiveness of every demon that's
ever lived and that's the Christ but
he's not he's not going after every
demon he's going after one specific
cultural reference which he knows pisses
a lot of people off the main one well
because he's doing the old talk about
what you can't say but if he's not
saying Genghis Khan he's not saying
Stalin he's not saying Mao zetong but he
was if he was but this is what some
people are trying to excuse this
Behavior as oh he's trying to piss
everyone off just to be more christ-like
just and there's is no way he's doing
that because if he did he would have
done it from a different way he would
have done it from a way of compassion
rather than trying to stir up a beehive
I don't know you're not always when
you're in a manic State you don't always
go for compassion if I was his manager
if I was Milo I would say listen you're
not going to be able to go on the
campaign Trail and actually articulate
these very nuanced subjects that are
very very hard because they're not black
and white they're very gray and he's not
going to be able to articulate that but
his best weapon and even said that he
stinks in music he thinks in harm and
he's you know you know Melodies so he
should if he really like wants to expose
A New World Order he should have an
anti-new World Order album make that go
number one but that's not what he wants
he wants a Ubi he wants sustainable
government housing for everyone
let me get my tin foil hat because this
is what Tavistock the Tavistock
Institute basically they you know they
do a lot of the Mind Control a lot of
the MK Ultra experimenting and they have
music that they use as propaganda
because they've actually done testing
that they know what harmonies and
Melodies are actually pleasurable for
our ears so it's like these places can
actually create music that doesn't like
addicting for us like that's why these
same artists are able to recreate you
know pop hits because a lot of them are
using the same Melody patterns like you
can actually look into it Tavistock like
they've actually had soldiers they put
them on drugs they put them sober they
had them listen to the music they tested
their heart rate they tested how they
feel if they want to dance if not so
they basically can have a cheat code and
I'm saying Kanye West I know you want to
talk real quick could hack into that
that's the only thing he can do him
saying uh the Nuance of the month but he
can't you know speak for himself to save
his life but a song that's the only way
I think he would be effective in getting
his message across there's that viral
video where this producer is like here's
I make a pop song and they take like a
young model they auto-tune her voice
then they he like breaks down the
structure of what pop music is they even
have our AIS that can auto-generate
Melodies and beats and then they craft
it into the perfect pop song
what Kanye is doing culturally is he's
speaking the harmony but there is no
Melody and people don't hear they don't
know what the melody is so it sounds
confusing like what are you saying about
yes there is goodness in people that we
think are evil that is like a harmonic
to well let's start with what we know
which is addicted to amphetamines
let me let me give a shout out to Ian
yin yang you've seen it right it's the
you know the White and the black there's
a dot in each of them of the opposing
color symbolizing that within light
there is dark within dark there is light
and the Sun and Moon right right it's
the duality of life but it's all but the
point I'm trying to make is that people
often don't realize it doesn't just mean
one against the other and I mean it also
means within the dark there is a Light
Within light there is dark that being
said I I can respect that point I think
we all understand the Nuance because the
conversation's been had about you know
even Hitler like dogs Mussolini made the
transfer on time but there's a reason
why we specifically highlight the really
evil things that came about from what
they've done because that is the the the
the bulk of their character yes we get
it humans share certain traits that we
we like but we're talking about the
specific unique components of a
particular individual and the bad things
they've done you know what I mean yeah
but it's weird that he's like
attributing things like the microphone
which Neumann made in 1928 in Germany
1930 I don't know someone can tell me in
the chat but Neumann made the microphone
why is attributing that and Hugo Boss
and Volkswagen to to Adolf or
architecture did he say why is it
happening I don't know but if you
wrapped it nobody would care but because
he's trying to say it then he has to be
like hey hey look shout out to uh Public
Enemy because when I was a little kid
they had that song in Tony Hawk Pro
Skater 2 Bring the Noise where they did
a team up with Anthrax and one of the
verses in that song because I used to
know all the words is farrakhan's a
prophet that I think you ought to listen
to what he can say to you
and I didn't know what that meant when I
was a little kid and that's in Tony
Hawk's Pro Skater that's one of the
greatest games of all time and then in
part two and then I grow up and I'm like
I wonder what that means and I look into
and I go holy what was in this game wow
dude and you loved it it was a song it
was like Turn It Up Bring the Noise and
I'm like yeah I'm like I had no idea
what it meant I think the one of the
problems that Kanye has been having is
the same as a similar problem what
Hitler was having which is that some
people were screwing with them and they
were Jewish so he blamed the entire
Jewish religion or is it I had to say
this and I hope this doesn't get me in
trouble though but it does prove Kanye a
little right as soon as they take away
his bank account I mean you know I mean
but it's this is the problem
because what's happening it's like you
had 30 dogs and 29 of them were Brown it
doesn't mean that most dogs are brown no
what what kanji is saying is abharan
discussing but it's just you know you
know him getting shut down and now it's
like I think he's doubling down the the
Trump where now he can't go back and be
like oh I didn't mean this I meant you
know there's just these few guys that's
he's just gone too far so when he's here
uh if you guys watch The Green Room
episode we did you'll understand my
point and I'll say a few things
I don't know for sure if it was staged
but what I know is they didn't confirm
the hotel that we got for them
they had initially asked that we get him
a flight for the morning of and leaving
immediately after the show it's not
possible to do that so they said okay
you know then the next morning is fine
when they arrived and the person
coordinating says I have your address
they said don't worry about it so after
everything goes down I'm told we never
actually gave him the address to where
they were staying the night they didn't
want it and they had a jet already
waiting for them at Frederick with a
crew available ready to go and there was
Paparazzi outside so I'm like I don't
know man but if you watch the Green Room
episode you'll see that yay was very
calm asking us questions smile on his
face talking about everything and there
was like no issue but as soon as the
camera turns on and we go live on the
show his demeanor flips I gotta talk
about Nazism man because this is like
we're just talking about what wraps into
wakanya and everything this it's all in
the vein Tim don't worry I got you baby
um I got you baby I like that not
Sublime being racist is is legal in the
American Republic breaking down
buildings smashing buildings burning
buildings is something that Nazis did
and that's also something that happened
two years ago Kanye was not burning down
buildings Kanye was being racist if you
want to call the Jewish people a race
which I I also have issues with because
I thing if you don't believe in God
you're not Jewish the tenet of being
Jewish is that you believe in a God and
you understand what it is and if you
just because of who your parents are in
your social club it's not a social club
don't don't don't be don't be violent do
not those are the things I mean these
you're allowed to talk and say that's
the Great
so well that's why hate speech should be
allowed because there's bad stuff you
can hate you know in the world so you
should be able to hate bad stuff so
that's why you should be able to have
hate speech but you shouldn't be able to
incite any sort of violence yeah Laura
Loomer came on the show and she was like
hey guys I'm Jewish I was debating
listen to this I gotta bring up Laura
Loomer I want to shout her out so she's
spreading this thing in telegram today
that Marjorie Taylor green and I had a
sexual Affair so I just want to debunk
that did you know no even though
Marjorie is a beautiful lady and and
I'll be honest I would if I could but I
haven't so I I so I can't so you know
that's the that's the real facts but to
be honest uh this is the sad reality for
congresswoman green for me even if we
did have sex I'm saying for me to leak
it that would be huge that'd be great
right for her it only you know hurts her
I just want to say the God's honest
truth it didn't happen I'd probably leak
it if it did it's my point AOC would be
mad at you exactly so that's why you
know it's not true but I just hate it
for her because I just hate it for her
because it's just so provably false and
she's the one looks bad for you know
even sleeping with this pile of junk
Prime Time 99 even though I'm a pimp on
a blimp a lot of ladies want to take a
ride still it just makes her look bad
because I'm just a you know Joe below
comedian from Dallas Texas how is any of
this real life this week has been just
really crazy
okay this is a vague question do you
think it's a simulation for real like
this I don't know I don't know I almost
believe in reincarnation I do believe in
the Creator they're like I just I don't
I really hate I talk about this all the
time the idea of the big bang and that
we evolved from Pawn scum and that just
nothing you know literally like
everything came from nothing over time
just for me doesn't even live but you
got to get way more nuanced than that
because I think the idea of like
Evolution and pawns come can be the how
not the why like there's people there's
even a biogenesis we can't recreate that
I mean it's just the fact that like you
think every single person here you and
me the cat like you see that cat it's so
beautiful it's just such a beautiful
creature like we are not the same it's
just I just do believe there is a
Creator and and does that mean that
there's you know more levels to this I
do believe I just do believe there is
that's I feel like this is a God thing
like this really is we're part of
something which is God's the
consciousness of real God like it is
there it's this is the which turns out
abrahamic religions Judea Judaism
Christianity Islam they were already
they were all right you got Ian started
now so like Kanye's going through some
like channeling you know he's and it's
coming out all wrong in a lot of ways in
a lot of ways not but in a lot of ways
it's coming out wrong let's we'll uh I
want to
let me tell you
I was watching this uh interview with
yay and Jones and Fuentes and I said
these are three guys who are having
everything taken away from them yay is
gonna he's gonna lose his kids he uh I
mean maybe what happened so I was just
talking about how his demeanor was so
different
he was on his phone the whole time the
show starts he's totally different
maybe that's when he found out about his
kids he mentioned something to us before
the show about his wife's lawyer being
really good like he looked at me he was
like they have my wife it looks like he
got a good deal though he got 50 50 with
200k a month uh well so but my point is
he's sitting here right before the show
starts and everything was fine he gets
mad and leaves may have nothing to do
with us at all yeah maybe maybe it was
planned maybe because he's on his phone
he gets that message I I get it so he's
a guy who then says on the show they're
trying to put me in jail they're
freezing my accounts he's going through
a divorce they're taking everything away
from him they're saying you know Adidas
tries stealing the name of his shoes
Alex Jones they're coming after for 2.75
trillion and Fuentes at one point was
banned from flying you take three guys
who have nothing left to lose and you're
good you'll get this or or or more and
this is why I'm I oppose cancel culture
and I say we should be having
conversations with these people let them
come in to the circle and work out the
issues because if you just say never not
a chance then they'll go wherever they
can go and they'll say we have nothing
to lose and they'll just do whatever
they want well that's what's kind of
stuck too about that interview as soon
as Nick was going to talk which
everybody wants to hear from Nick I mean
you know he's one of the most polarizing
people within any political ideology
whether you're on the left lining or
right lane and as soon as he's about to
say something then Kanye leaves it just
sucks Nick is so interesting he's one of
the most interesting people whether you
like him or not and it just kind of
sucks so that we miss out on that
opportunity even as much as almost as
Kanye because when you listen to Kanye
talk he doesn't he can't articulate his
opinions and that's my opinion even
though Kanye's a brilliant artist I just
don't think publicly speaking on these
subjects in a long-form podcast is his
specialty it seems like he almost wants
to get canceled he was wearing a
Balenciaga mask today on the Alex Jones
uh pop you know interview when he was
here he was wearing a Balenciaga jacket
people are getting canceled because they
don't disavow Valencia Balenciaga he's
still wearing it as he's talking about
the most craziest outlandish things that
he knows will get people talking about
it we'll get people riled up some people
are saying that this is a deliberate
suicide of his career
um I I think that's also another
possibility here some people are saying
that there's clear you know problems uh
mentally here who knows I I don't know I
I can't really quantify it I'm just kind
of you know why she's just shocked at
all this to be honest with you why is he
wearing a Balenciaga mask it's a [ __ ]
masks
it's 160 Balenciaga I think it's he's
indicating that he's been gimped by the
that establishment I think that's what
that is supposed to be I mean he's worn
it for concerts before as well mind you
and then Jones even made the point is it
really even him he said maybe he'll take
the mask off is it really even yeah he's
not Andy Kaufman
that'd be brilliant if he did I mean
then they say there's like oh the real
conspiratory is he a clone I mean I
don't believe that either but I mean
he's you know Kanye he's not he's not
his right state of mind and his mom did
die you know that that messes you up I
know that sounds excuse for him to act
insane and become a you know a radical
Nazi but I don't think he really is I
just I think he's a little misunderstood
as well as as crazy as he's being right
now regarding this is I want a question
for you particularly about um becoming
like the Andy Kaufman character becoming
the villain for Society for them to
focus on I kind of did that in 2010 it
didn't work out like I just angered
upset the environment instead of like
creating a bunch of good around me but
do you think one do you think that he's
he or Nick or Milo are doing that and do
you think that there's any value to it
no because it's like I'm not an expert
but it's Saul alinsky's Rules for
Radicals and that's kind of like using
the less you know guidebook against him
and like you know they would use
creativity to protest and stuff him
speaking about it he needs to be using
his best methodology which would be
music to get his point across so he's
not doing that so he's just being it's a
waste of talent but in Saul's you know
in Saul linsky's rules for radical it's
like you accuse the people of what
you're actually doing so he's not being
nuanced he's not being smart he's just
being like Hitler quote unquote in a
video game I don't get in trouble but
he's saying Kanye West I don't want them
to edit this is saying Hitler is you
know not a bad person so that is what
Kanye West is saying and that is just
two nobody is ever going to drive with
that under any circumstance I I so I
think I think it was really good that
Alex Jones had them on because look at
what we got to see everybody can make up
their mind about exactly what happened
and I said I believe this is a strong
argument for free speech if Alex was
censored and they were behind if they
and they were just hanging out in his
living room saying all this stuff nobody
would have any idea what yay believed
and what yay was was was working on or
working towards or who he was
associating with uh you might you might
likewise whatever he's entitled to his
opinion he's entitled to being a human
and believing what he wants to believe
because Alex Jones had them on a talk
about it they just said everything
now I'm curious your thoughts about uh
Alex Jones is uh demeanor I suppose and
I'll just come out and say when Kanye
outright says
you know he denies certain elements of
the Holocaust I'll put it that way Alex
Jones just says oh yeah Reagan said that
you know and and then and then what is
what does Jones say that I think Hitler
did Target and kill some people and it's
just like
can't can't Jones just come out more
definitively and be like look man you
know like there are there's people on
record there's historical record
what do you guys think about you know
how he handled the interview well
there's also that thing when you have
guests on your show you're trying to be
nice to them so I don't know maybe he's
just trying to you know appease his
guess that's no excuse but I and I've
talked to Alex I've been on a show he
always does that and I know Luke has a
relationship with him but and and this
is once again I'm I'm
I am defending everybody tonight but I'm
almost doing it to be you know
contrarian but I think Alex Jones is
very nice to his guest he wants to
please Kanye he realizes this is huge
for him this is a huge bump so he
realizes you know business-wise this
would be very a very key relationship
for him to build so I think that's why
he's trying to appease to him but also
you can have that caveat oh well you
know he's not he didn't go full what did
they say in that movie Tropical Thunder
oh yes yes yes
um yes it takes a lot to leave Alex
Jones speechless and uncomfortable
because of speech and Kanye West did it
um and Alex had an easy way out here I
think you know you should always be
genuine when you're doing these type of
type of broadcasts if if anyone here
says something that I disagree with I'm
going to bring it up and say hey I see
things differently we have discussions
we have debates we have arguments all
the time here on this broadcast because
we're we're honest with each other we're
genuine and I felt like Alex was kind of
going along with it and feeling
extremely uncomfortable not knowing what
to do not disagreeing not pushing back a
lot he did say that that uh that yay has
a Hitler fetish
um he did push back a little bit but
when when we're talking about these
short clips making the rounds of the
internet there's something there that
you always gotta kind of point out being
like hey are you on the side of Prescott
Bush hey are you on the side of of of of
Margaret Sanger George Soros Arnold
Schwarzenegger because these figures
also endorsed this larger ideology that
now you're promoting you're really
you're really with with uh Arnold
Schwarzenegger who says he he really
loves he he really adored and liked you
know Hitler and he had a father that was
also tied to the SS I confronted Arnold
Schwarzenegger about this face to face
by the way in one of my YouTube videos
on we are change but
um again that could have been a very
easy out for Jones but he didn't he
didn't do it which is weird I think if
he I think if Joe Alex probably thought
if he told Kanye no Hitler did Kill six
million Jews that Kanye would have got
up and walked out like he's probably
like oh how do I not make Kanye walking
I mean in case and then once again I
carry the water but Alex Jones is
arguably one of the greatest
broadcasters of all time and when it
comes to internet and comes to Legendary
and comes to Alex Jones's right and some
of the stuff that he foresaw but right
now he is slipping he's under you know
so much stress with it with all these
constant lawsuits so that's what I'm
saying he's not his normal self so yeah
too yeah yeah either both of them that's
why they're both kind of a little
desperate right now do just just you
know to defend them a little bit with
their behavior when yay came in to do
the show on Tuesday Monday Tuesday
Monday he was like they're trying to put
me in jail we're like what are you
talking about he's like they're trying
to hit me with that hardly there's well
and that Harley passionate guy which
Luke brought up that worked for the
Canadian military psyop you know
organization whatever it was did say
like oh we're gonna put you on drugs and
your visits with your children are going
to be terrible that's weird that's
psychological manipulation when you
throw in the kids that's what like an
ex-wife does you know especially with
like the trans stuff that's what happens
in a lot of the instances where there's
a young kid that's you know
transitioning it's oftentimes like a
parent that has beef with the other
parent yeah and there's an apparent
encouraging yeah that's oftentimes the
case
he got drugged by 2018 or whenever that
was they drugged him up he's in a place
that not I don't think many humans can
identify with personally because he's
such a focal point and that kind of
stress you know and then to think that
handlers might actually not have your
best interests in mind that's just going
to mess people up you know but hearing
him hearing they were going to hit with
a 50 million or however much this tax
bill was is like that's probably what
was going through his mind 50 million I
think that's that's nuts that's like
what kind of stress that would put
somebody under yep and they can just say
it and what do you do like oh you owe us
this money and that's what I was we
talked about the 87 000 IRS agents and
this is this is the thing they do you'll
be like you're working class one day you
get a letter in the mail saying you know
we don't have to audit you you just owe
us 600 bucks and then what do you do you
you're not gonna you have to pay it they
can just do that and that's I think
everybody understands the stresses of
dealing with the IRS and they do it
already and they're going to be doing it
a lot more especially if you don't
report anything or you know over 600
you're you're going to be in trouble
they're going to punish you the Parlor
deal got canceled
we're talking a little bit about it and
uh oh look at that it's about me and um
it's it's in the space of you know Alex
Jones but we have this tweet from Elijah
Shafer it's a clip from his show where
Kanye disses me and uh okay I'll just
play it for you guys here you go you
ready the temple is the MPC you know and
you're a real a real human being so no
one's ever heard of uh Tim fool you know
you're the legend that is Alex Jones and
you were fighting on the front line and
now we're here with you you got some
other Superheroes part of the avenger
movie fighting for Christ so apparently
he said that I don't know that's what I
was told uh he I got a phone call 10
minutes before the show and I was told
what to say yeah you got contacted
before
like right before this like literally
those are the words right before he says
actually he's an NPC the hour before the
show we are sitting in this room right
hanging out talking as the cameras are
being adjusted uh surge is getting
things ready people are grabbing drinks
so it just literally didn't happen but I
got a beef you can call me an NPC and
say nobody's heard of me I I defer to
Alex Jones I mean that guy's been around
he was he was doing this work 10 years
before I even heard of you know a phone
before I even got anywhere near doing
this kind of stuff well Tim you're a
true populist when you know when when
you're Kanye West who's saying you know
quote unquote Hitler wasn't that bad of
a guy that's not very exactly a populist
opinion so to him you know you are an
NPC no offense but you're not and uh but
I can see why that's why he's calling
you that do you understand but I I
wonder like
like why he came here you know what I
mean I think maybe maybe Milo was like
No it's it's a good show it's it's it's
it's you know they get like a million
something views with their Clips or
something like that I don't know well he
has a little bit of a media blackout
from what I understand from what
happened with what he said on Tucker and
all that stuff you know yeah I do
believe a lot of media companies right
now will not platform so you're one of
the few ones and the big you're the
biggest Independent Media broadcaster
you and then Infowars right there I mean
daily wire had him on Boom Candace is
canceled he can't go back on there Blaze
we haven't had him on so and Kanye and I
say this you can come on my show my
Show's coming out very soon and the
blaze is going to be mad that I said
that but Kanye was welcome on my show
I'll jump on a blimp let's go Kanye all
day and I'm gonna be nice to you I'll
let you guys in on some uh internal
stuff uh when we were originally trying
to book their accommodation for the
night the hotel uh wouldn't let us do it
we don't know exactly what happened you
said it's for Kanye West why not just
say like uh you have to do credit card
authorization so when you book a hotel
this is the most annoying thing about
traveling anybody who travels for work
knows exactly what this is your company
will book your hotel and you'll show up
and they'll say and you have a credit
card on fi and you're like my company
booked it with the company card
place it sucks right yes and so what we
have to do is we have to call in and
confirm our card details for the room
and as soon as we said who would be
checking like when you're when you're
booking a room you got to put their name
on it how else do they show up and give
you the name and then then they're just
like we'll get back to you and put us on
hold and then it was like an hour later
of like hold on we're talking to the
manager and then we're like okay this is
not working we're just sitting on the
phone so we canceled it we got an Airbnb
I wonder if uh
there's there's some other stuff I want
to respect their privacy to a certain
degree but uh
even when it came to other travel
details there were like you know he's
getting his accounts locked he's saying
that they're coming after himself like
that and then that happened and we don't
we don't think too much about it but I'm
wondering if that's a component I guess
he was able to get a private plane you
know so he's still able to do something
so I don't get it I don't know man
no idea but uh the one thing I do wonder
is
you know when he came here
I'm getting attacked by two different
groups
one group is saying that I shouldn't
have said a single word how dare you you
should have just let him keep talking
okay and the other side saying I didn't
push back enough I should have been not
letting him talk and pushing back on by
this is crazy but Alex Jones actually
does interrupt him a couple times and
and he seems totally fine with it yeah
he keeps reminding him that it's Kanye's
show he's like he interrupts him Alex
will be like well I'm just thinking and
it's your show you're you're in the
control here but and then Alex will say
so he keeps reminding yay that it's
yay's interview you're here I'm just
throwing this in he got testy a little
bit where you saw like a lot of tension
and you clearly saw Alex Jones being
very uncomfortable in that situation and
of course he pushed back eventually but
when they're making these small clips
and they're going viral on the internet
when you're just saying yeah yeah yeah
after something someone says something
controversial that you know that that
that everyone's sharing those videos and
now pointing fingers at AJ did they
bring like if you're going to say that
Hitler did not kill six million people
you better have the data and the facts
to back that up right there in your hand
that's such an insane like a powerful
statement to go up online without any
pushback or evidence and there was no
pushback but
I I whatever I guess I mean like I
mentioned this earlier cernovich said we
dodged a bullet I saw that said that's a
Luke and Luke you were saying well we
would have debated we would have had a
conversation we probably would have been
screaming here and maybe that
conversation needed to be had I mean
maybe he needed to know about Margaret
Sanger maybe he needed to know about how
he's on team establishment by promoting
a lot of this population control
Eugenics nonsense I don't think he knows
what he's talking about a lot of the
times he was referring to Nick to answer
his questions Whenever there was even a
little bit of pushback Nick was laughing
the whole time enjoying the show and
then going on and expanding on points
that clearly yay couldn't articulate so
with that with all these people here
they would have brought up their idea we
would have smashed it down be like no we
don't agree with this because of this
and this and this and then it would have
been a conversation it would probably
would have been an argument probably
would have been screaming maybe maybe
there's a small chance that there would
have been some kind of understanding and
and I think it was it was still worth it
in order to have that small possibility
because that would have changed
everything I just want to mention too
that uh when yay was here he said he
didn't want to be on the show
he said that before yeah he also said he
also said we got to do the show every
single uh
that means he
just showed Oh no no no no no no
and then but then we were we were like
maybe if this goes well we'll see what
happens
and he was like he was like this will go
well I'm like oh
yeah we don't know he's an artist he's
like oh let's collab let's collab I mean
I'm just guessing that's it I'll clarify
clarify because Luke is right what he
said was something like these guys keep
trying to get me to do these podcasts
but something I'm paraphrasing he's like
there's no point me coming on this I
don't want to do it but then
you give me information like this and he
points on his notepad where he wrote
down ballot harvesting right because he
asked me downstairs in the in the
basement in the skate park he asked me
as we're walking up the stairs he was
like I want to know how to become
president how do I become president him
and it was like I just said I I don't
know Milo knows and then as we're
walking away he goes you know I asked
you how to become president you ignored
me and I said oh that was up here no no
we're walking up the stairs oh again and
then I said no I I said Milo knows I'm
I'm not I'm not I'm just a guy on the
internet man I'm a guy who complains on
the internet then we're sitting down he
said the same thing he's like you know I
asked you twice how to become president
you keep ignoring me and then I was like
okay ballot harvesting and he was like
what's what's that and I explained how
bad harvesting works and he was like
whoa and he writes it down and then he
brings up how he didn't want to be here
basically like they want him to do these
shows he doesn't want to do it but then
he gets something like that and makes it
worth it I kind of just think he didn't
want to be here yeah he didn't he was
honest he I mean he goes where he wants
does what he wants and he's like I'll
use I bet Milo was like Yay if you want
to become president Tim pulls the guy he
he has a huge Reach people trust him
he's brilliant let's go and he's like
yes I want to be president unless I
don't I don't think Milo said I think
that's I think that's why they came and
why they all came together you kind of
baby Joe Rogan it's like Joe Rogan but
he's like the Rogan apology no he's like
a politics guy yeah I I my my view is
probably that he said
this is a show that's got a decent reach
that we can go on he'll probably have us
of course that's probably he's asking me
how he can win I mean he's already
asking like an advisor like what can I
do but why would he fly six hours six
hours one way he got nothing going on
man
and then sit down here for like 20
minutes if I come out yeah like oh you
don't you don't believe everything I
gave him cookies he took some on the way
out yeah well what was that deal because
he goes this isn't going to be a Lex
Friedman deal again you know he said
that and I was like this wasn't even
like that argument over Judaism that's
what it comes down to I'm so concerned
with this argument too because it really
is important to do differentiate between
the religion and the culture it's the
only religion on Earth that has a
attached Birthright bloodline to it
which is kind of weird and probably
illogical and like just because your
parents are a certain way doesn't mean
that you believe in God and but the
tenets of Judaism is that you believe in
God so like I don't want people saying
they're Jewish and then being abusive to
humans and and giving the faith a bad
name yeah hey butcher tell me Tim I
remember you left during the podcast for
a minute did you ever go out there
because I know Luke talked to him but
did you ever talk to them outside no
they're in the oh never no when I got up
uh it was to try and figure out what
they were doing with their accommodation
and and like I was saying like like
whether you should get their plane or
whatever well I'm like yeah well we we
got him a round trip flight and all that
stuff and I'm like what are you guys
doing and they're like don't worry we're
taking care of it that's what I was
trying to figure out look I said to him
I was like I I immediately messaged Milo
like so like what's going on and then uh
because we we booked their accommodation
and stuff and they just said we're
taking care of it don't worry about it
and I said okay and that's what that's
what I was trying to take care of I
don't want to talk on the phone I didn't
call him I was calling the travel agency
and stuff like that and so uh I couldn't
take those calls here live you know what
I mean private details of where they're
going to be and stuff like that so and
that was about it and I told him I was
like bro I'm not even mad it is what it
is yeah he owes me nothing we we invite
people to come on because it's a benefit
to us we don't pay guests you know you
being here is a benefit to us that's
that's what it is so and Ian came in he
was emotional everybody was emotional it
was really a good episode you know it's
good I'm saying you know it seems like
it was bad but it was I think it you
know it was in the grand scheme if you
can back off and look at it from like a
10 million foot view you're going to
look at this moment in history of like
that was the first meeting between
Temple and Kanye West maybe maybe
um I don't I don't like celebrity
culture stuff I don't like the pr plan
stuff
I don't like the okay here's the plan
we're gonna go on a show but you need to
storm out Midway through and that's
that's Hollywood celebrity culture I
don't want to be involved in any of that
it's just yeah but that's all fake and
dumb but people love it it's just I
don't say it's poison you know I think
it's like sugar people are allowed to
have that stuff they're allowed to like
that stuff there's so many there's so
many YouTube channels that love drama
that uh you know they they want to find
anything they can about anybody it's
like what The Young Turks turned into
like political WWE and that's and that's
kind of insulting a WWE because we know
that they're having fun yeah but like
turning the political space into uh
you like a stage crap show yeah just
like it's like it's like this is this is
something that I just don't like about
YouTube is my advice to all these
YouTubers who want to do shows is just
don't talk about each other don't talk
about personal stuff talk about bigger
issue things like you know how how
people's lives are being impacted by
policy how politicians are are either
lying or telling truth what you know
what is in control of their lives or in
control of their minds what is affecting
them Fair Point that commentators do
have an influence Joe Rogan says
something and it becomes news because so
influential I totally understand that
but there's there's so much of like
watching the social space devolve and
probably the saddest example is The
Young Turks how it's like jenk and Anna
just screaming at me like they're not
making any arguments they're just
calling me a loser a [ __ ] Jank is doing
this weird chicken thing where he goes
back and forth and I'm I'm not trying to
drag them by saying this I'm trying to
you know I don't like talking about them
because I don't think they're relevant
but they do exemplify how the space is
is turning into into this like celebrity
you know I don't like it I don't want to
be involved it's like Jerry Springer but
uh more degenerate and low IQ I bet
today uh sbf's like yes yes yes I mean
he's already on a big PR media tour with
the with the corporate media glorifying
him but I just wish I mean a lot of this
is drama a lot of those a lot of this is
just like you girl kind of stuff between
between dudes I I just wish we would
talk about Jeffrey Epstein as much as we
do Kanye West if we if the media would
just be focused on where Jeffrey Epstein
was going who he was meeting with what
he was saying like they are but Kanye
the world would be a better place if
just FB SBF would get as much attention
as Nick Fuentes my goodness please
please we could only dream Sam bankman
freed is his name yeah but we'll just
not not just Sam but also you have to
remember you have to look into Jimmy
Seville too and that's why you know I
think that's so important because that
gives you the context if you're like wow
there's people this powerful and this
guy was knighted by the queen and he was
literally probably the worst cereal
child rapist of all time as a matter of
fact not just that he did even worse
stuff that we can't mention on this show
yeah
it's absolutely like the most like
Monsters Beyond even understanding for
most human beings sorry go ahead and so
when you realize that there are people
that are at the highest upper echelon of
society that are actually doing terrible
stuff to children and you see the you
know time that Bill Gates spent with
Jeffrey Epstein that they're all
connected through prince Andrew who's
connected through the royal family who
you can even see Glenn Maxwell and
Jeffrey Epstein are sitting in a cabin
that is like the most exclusive Royal
cabin that there is some Swiss Chalet or
something I don't know if you guys are
familiar with the photo that I'm talking
about oh yes you know and so the fact
that they would have access to the queen
you know they were hanging out with
Kevin Spacey Kevin Spacey was in the
queen chair it's like this is like a
form of drama like what we're doing
right now is Gossip just on a level of
people we don't know personally cereal
see this is this is different this is
Criminal Predators happening with Bill
Clinton on the Lolita Express 26 times
on the flight log that we know of with
no secret service this guy is the top
guy and we know that if you look at his
pattern of behavior what he did in the
Oval Office with Monica Lewinsky shows
you that he's willing to do stuff
because he is a sexual deviant and does
not follow the rules so if you think
that he's going to Jeffrey Epstein's
Island addiction she could service yeah
and that's what I'm saying no secret
service to go to St James Island just to
drink some uh uh you know whatever pina
coladas I'm sorry but you're dreaming
but when I say drama I'm talking about
doing a show where you're like did you
see that guy when he was drinking that
that that beer wow what a what a dumbass
versus that guy's on a plane with
children to a private island they're
trafficking you made a good point that
it's criminal talking about criminal
criminal Behavior especially file
criminal Behavior it's not just that
it's the government it's how your life
is being affected it's how they're
they're harming your children it's how
they're destroying your property it's
eminent domain it's a violation of the
Constitution these things will make it
the these things are evil people
criminal people these are politicians
lying cheating stealing has a direct
impact on the survivability of humanity
and the future of this country and our
culture and the world and then the other
thing is I saw a guy walk outside and he
was eating a bucket of ice cream what an
idiot yeah I think it's like a fractal
and let me explain that like drama is
good in small doses gossip is good in
small doses because you need to know
who's crazy if someone around here is
going to go nuts everyone needs to know
so we can make sure that guy's not here
um and that's why communities would
gossip so you can learn about yourself
through gossip through watching other
people deal with drama and that's good
but if it overtakes you the conversation
that's bad in my opinion let's pull up
this story here this is big news CNBC
reports yay's deal to buy conservative
social media at parlor is called off
conservative social media company Paul
said Thursday it's dealt it's deal to be
bought by yay has been called off the
rapper formerly known as Kanye West
agreed to buy the app in October for an
undisclosed amount yeah has made
repeated public anticipated comments in
recent and several business Partnerships
involving the musician have been
terminated I don't know exactly
um why they say quote the company has
mutually agreed with you to terminate
the intent of sale of parlor the app's
parent company said in a statement this
decision was made in the interest of
both parties in mid-november parlor will
continue to pursue future opportunities
for growth and the evolution of the
platform for our Vibrant Community he
brought this up in the pre-show he was
saying he said something negative about
it like I forgot what it was he was
asking me you were trying to unload it
off of me like are they trying to he's
talking to I think it was news me knows
me okay and uh Tim he was asking no no
even before that he was talking to Nick
before you even came in when you were
talking about federating parlor because
you came up here that's the Federation
fractals uh break the code and all the
stuff that you always say but before
that he was like do you think they're
trying to just unload offload this on me
and put it on me I didn't have enough
details I didn't know how to answer him
and um I don't know if they were trying
to sell him 100 of the company or if
they just wanted to buy in 30 as a
figurehead I don't know the detail sales
what what I think happened here is
Adidas took or his money disappeared so
he doesn't have the money to buy parlor
now and that's probably why he ended the
deal I think he said he still had 400
million dollars but because he has a
third of his value he's like ah now this
is going to become 700 percent of my uh
expected Investments but Adidas is is
demanding 250 million dollars and and
put a hold on his account and the IRS is
demanding 50 million dollars so he's not
in a place to spend 400 million bucks on
a social network plus the divorce with
us lawyers plus fees that's my guess my
guess is that he just ran out of funds
breach of contract rules that probably a
lot of the other companies that he's
working with also have didn't he also
say that Adidas was going to buy the
name off of him yeah they're going to
start making basically making these
issues no they said they were going to
buy the name so they could keep using it
oh okay yeah I wonder if they also
announced that they're gonna release the
same shoes just not with his name on it
that's why I'm saying I'm pretty sure he
said in the pre-show that they're trying
to buy the name from him like basically
give him a lump sum cut him out
interesting okay well if you're
listening yay you probably did the right
thing by not buying it like Elon lives
and breathes Twitter right now he sleeps
in the office and if you're a CEO of a
tech company you got to meet Bill ottman
at mines 10 12 hours a day that guy for
the last 15 12 years that is his life is
mines and you need to be like that if
you want to be a successful CEO of a
tech company well and this is what I
think about like the future of digital
media and that's why I look at what Tim
is doing is so important because like
all these cable channels are dying they
die like really quick but I believe the
future will be like how they have an
audio only RSS feed that soon there'll
be a video only or you know like a video
RSS feed and you'll be able to pick a
platform and you'll be able to choose
which content you want so whether it's
any sort of video or it's Audio Only I
think that will be the future because
you know the media that we have today
where people are paying for you know
their cable like it is I think that's
going to die really soon we're working
on technology with the foundation that
I'm starting where you'll have your own
software packet that you can upload
video to ideally or rumble or or your
own server or something um the when we
launch it it's going to be pretty Alpha
and then the idea is you'll be able to
it'll to see your mind stuff your
Twitter your Rumble maybe your parlor
maybe not I don't know if they're going
to open source their code Tim what are
you smiling about I'm looking at those
chips just thinking about oh he's ready
to do it because we spent an hour
talking about Kanye we got to go insane
for the Ukraine already wait okay we can
do it so that wasn't no timer no we're
gonna do it we can wait let's wait a
little bit yeah I got three we're gonna
get all you to three people
so you guys are talking about the future
of digital me I think it's very
important and while you were talking I
looked over and saw that we have three
of those crazy blue fire chips and I was
just thinking about the last time Alex
ate one and it was hilarious and so Alex
is like what are you laughing about and
I I don't want to I want to derails one
two you have one too is he even gonna do
it as well
but I'll do it again I'm Not Afraid see
I'm a pimp on a blimp so these are bad
chemical no no no no no blue one that's
right here man stay away the worst
occasion oh I love that one
sunflower oil is bad flower oil bad
that's the good one yeah
what are they saying in the chat we're
looking at it guys we're going uh blue
in the chat so you guys want me to do a
two-piece I think we should put these in
a case on the wall
we'll just let's we
you can see the aftermath of Alex's
first Blue Chip Fiesta on Twitter on I
think it's Alex
uh yeah I mean uh it was insane for the
Ukraine like it keeps saying but okay
yeah real quick before I eat this but
what do you guys think about all the
money that we're giving to Ukraine do
you think that will ever stop and do you
think we're going to go into World War
III because I know you're Mr Civil War
so what about World War III or you know
Mr World War III so after today
so this morning I tweeted I think yay
could be president and so I had a con so
we were putting together uh the The
Green Room episode it finished rendering
this morning we watched it started
having a conversation with my brother
about what happened and I was like a lot
of what happened feels like 2016
Playbook with Trump
and my brother was like you really think
he could get elected president after
saying this stuff about Jewish people
and I was like I don't know but the
media reported that Trump said Mexicans
were all rapists and that he wanted to
ban he had a Muslim ban and all that
stuff and he still gets votes so I
wonder if this is a maximized press
strategy and so then when I was thinking
about it I'm like I'm not going to
underestimate this guy I mean this this
this dude is summons a private jet the
snap of a fingers kind of guy and uh I
said that
and then he went on Alex Jones's show
and then I said okay well boy was I
wrong about that because because he went
off
however some I I tweeted I'm gonna keep
this tweet up eat eat this one because
boy was I wrong about that there are a
lot of people that are like you're wrong
about a lot of things I'm like yes I
acknowledge that absolutely but then
someone said
I don't know man you might have been
right the first time because this this
everything's like going crazy and
breaking down like this past week has
been nuts yeah the past month has been
just weird and crazy it seems like
everything's just getting crazy do you
think that do you think that's weird
that the Secretary of State Katie Hobbs
can certify our own election in a
contentious place where the machines
broke down today you think there's
anything like you know tinfoil Hattie uh
conspiratorial about that no I mean uh I
do and when let's just say the the only
election that was more fair and accurate
than the 2020 election was the 2022
election oh and I want to say this this
is another thing and and I know this is
probably an unpopular opinion in the
conservative world but because I'm truly
a populist and it's not really what I
want it's what the people want but
everybody's like oh in the conservative
we gotta get we gotta get Dr Oz we need
Dr Oz and I'm like are you idiots
smoking weed or something we need
fetterman Lurch this guy's a Content
King dude got Jersey Giselle in there
they're gonna have all kinds of talk
about drama you think Marjorie Taylor
green is interesting you think AOC wait
till Lurch is up in there he can barely
wear a tie he's got a thing growing out
of his neck the size of freaking Jupiter
I mean the guy's insane so I love you
congratulations Mr fetterman what about
Walker what about her Senator fetterman
are you excited about uh Walker yeah
well and this is the other thing with
Herschel this is the only thing that
bugs me is like yeah I mean you know and
the people like oh he does better in the
debate this and that you know warnock's
the worst because I hate these guys they
act like they're pastors but then
they're pro-choice like give me a break
like I get why some people are
pro-choice I'm not I'm against abortion
I think it's terrible personally but I
hate when these pastors are like oh I'm
I love Jesus I love Jesus but I think
you know you should be able to you know
have abortion I just think that goes
against God so that's the worst but I
just don't like that freaking my man
Herschel Walker just can't be like yeah
I had an abortion I did some stuff come
on I mean I changed my mind because this
is what life is life is about the
freaking caterpillar becoming the
butterfly we're all supposed to change
we're not supposed to be the same and
there's something that's actually
likable about that somebody that can go
from bad to good so I don't know I just
don't like when they lie and guys let me
tell you something this is another thing
idolizing a politician is like thinking
the stripper actually likes you you got
no chance Herschel Walkers Are Gonna
Save Your Butt Dr Oz Ain't Gonna Save
You Katie
she said certainly I mean Kerry Lake's
great so they say she's going to be
Trump's VP give me a break should be my
queen merger Taylor green but I'm just
saying it's all fake and lame and I hate
to say it transsexual at this point
because nothing matters like you know
both sides it's rigged against us and I
really have really no faith in uh the
system so I think it's just about being
civilly disobedient and having a good
life the a life that uh once it gets as
big as Kanye they can take away from you
in an instant so treat your life like
that and just enjoy it I I agree with a
lot of that the Civil Disobedience stuff
this is why I said it feels like things
are getting crazier and crazier uh it's
it's just like the news cycle is more
and more absurd every single day yeah I
think they were in the Apocalypse in the
second coming of Christ is upon us
statement but the news the news cycle
too has been a little slow in the fact
that I mean I'm not saying that as a
disrespect to you the fact that you're
leading it but it's like people are
we're like starving for news like you
know because they don't want to talk
about the elephant in the room like you
know the Epstein don't excuse me not
Epstein talk about 100 Biden laptop like
there's other stuff they want to talk
about but they you know they want to
talk about Kanye all day long because
it's basically like he's like Trump
there's a revolution he's not Trump
there's a revolution happening in China
right now exactly
Factory I mean there's so many important
things that we could be talking about
health obesity levels are increasing to
such dangerous level sperm levels are
going down to where people in a few
decades will need to have assisted
helped when it comes to reproducing like
like we're at a crisis of civilization
and and yay is the main thing of of
discussion come on man the whole chat
exploded with en20 based off what he
just said hell yes that's because it's
real dude we are in an inflection point
with the internet video where our minds
are melding and it's time for the Christ
energy to come out of us each of us
individually it requires each of us to
speak our mind together we can do it
well I don't know what that means
congratulations for being here with me
well it is people are also asking if you
dropped acid today no no no but but Ian
has a point because I think I talked
about this last time but we are you know
energetic beings so we're vibrational so
we can either be high vibrational or low
vibrational and like that's why they say
misery you know loves company we are
like we're like energetic like magnets
so you're right that that's our
christ-like energy with within us and so
we kind of tend to you know uh gravitate
towards people that have that similar
energy they call it sympathetic
vibration and science where one object
will vibrate and then another one of the
similar structure across the room will
start to vibrate so the human bone for
instance is a crystal yeah Crystal
people are saying Ian 20 and even Ian
100 after that last one I'm telling you
man this is what's happening it's this
is either either it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy that humans want is someone to
step up and become the second coming or
I think all of us together are creating
the second coming of the Christ energy
you never never put your faith in one
individual preach Ian and I love what we
have in the chat because I'm always in
the chat every single episode I try to
read every single chat and whenever
someone makes a point there's some Grace
in the chat my man is great man everyone
ends in chat always writes at everyone's
performance from one to twenty and you
can see one or Twenty yeah but sometimes
it's 15 sometimes it's five it depends
yeah and it's it's usually you're right
it usually is one or Twenty but I think
that's awesome in the chat room and it's
good seeing that feedback automatically
I picture so keep ranting I pictured an
alternate uh reality where I ran after
Kanye when they left and then had a
conversation with him and he was like
let's go back in and we come back in and
the Articles were like that would have
read Kanye West Storms off of Tim pool
interview comes back with Jesus and it
just shows Kanye with a frown like same
frown on his face but I'm there next to
him because people tell me I look like
Jesus well the whole episode you're
hoping that Kanye comes back you're like
is he gonna come back is he gonna he was
hanging up that would have been that
would have been the episode that changed
the world if he came back and I was
sitting there and people were like that
guy looks like Jesus Christ is here like
I'm not saying I'm not I'm I want to be
like Jesus he inspired me that that idea
that someone could be like that in
reality that I I it's I like long hair
you know whatever I don't really care
about the look it's just that's what I
want well and to say that like I think
that's why it's important though that
you do Platform people like Nick Fuentes
Tim because like people like you said
why it was important for them to go on
Alex Jones to hear their thoughts so
it's like you know that's why it just
sucks because the people wanted him to
come on so bad I wanted to hear both of
them when they left I'm just like
sitting there like oh so anti-climactic
it's it's it's kind of a crazy thing too
because I know there's a lot of things
that people don't like what he said
they've made fun of a lot of things that
he said but he says a lot of things that
a lot of people would agree with when
he's uh he was talking about nationalism
he was talking about working class stuff
like you don't get to hear that you only
get to hear the worst possible thing and
that's probably one of the reasons why
they don't want someone like him to have
a platform of course I think he believes
things that are that are wrong
completely disagree with but then he'll
also say something where you're like oh
okay then then it's humanizing if
someone like Fuentes can come on and say
he's not racist that he actually he
thinks he people are different but
everybody can get along you can call
them you can call him a liar and all
that stuff but have the conversation
it's the perfect allegory of Christ he
was defending the weakest of the
prostitute it was like if any of you are
a sinless then criticize who here has
not done something wrong they would get
them canceled every one of us has done
that um
that Ian once explained how to make
chloramine gas
yeah he's uh he's vibing he's vibrating
literally yeah man this has been on my
mind a lot but I just have to admit and
you know for you know for me once again
being a stand Nick Fuentes is hilarious
and he's funny and I do think he is a
little misunderstood because I really
don't think you know now Kanye where
he's going I just I think he's watched a
lot of those you know Black Hebrew
Israelite type doctors yeah Farrakhan so
he's kind of like in that like oh you
know there's an evil cabal of people you
know the Jewish Illuminati you know I
think Nick's uh maybe was in that at one
point and kind of realized it's a little
nuanced because let me just tell you
something I'm a full-blown conspiracy
theorist there is an evil group of
people but it's from all different
groups of religion and Society it's not
one you know it's a secret group we're
not in it but it's not just one group
that no because I know so many great
Jewish of every you know denomination so
it's just it's not that's not but you
didn't say the Illuminati yeah
okay did you guys see the Jimmy Kimmel
video about Fuentes I think it was Jimmy
Kimmel right
foreign played a clip of Fuentes talking
about how there are gay men who have
slept with women so that must mean being
who said that Fuentes
that was hilarious did they not realize
he was joking like it was a bit like he
was being funny and they were like haha
look at how dumb he is and it's like you
guys you missed a joke he's being
sarcastic it was it was it was a bit and
it was funny and this this happens all
the time on Twitter and it's become like
a meme where like the left doesn't
understand when someone is being
sarcastic or making a joke they think
everything's literal yeah it's just it's
kind of weird to be honest I I once was
was saying that one of the divides in
the culture war is the right is willing
to believe certain things may be jokes
and that could be dangerous when they're
not but they're willing to look for the
humor and and try and give someone the
benefit of the doubt and the left thinks
everything is literal all the time yeah
obviously I literally all the time they
think things are literal like many of
them will take everything literally even
when I like I tweeted something like uh
the the intelligence agencies that
crafted me into a personality had it
right propped someone up to take all the
heat off to off to have a conversation
with my Handler and I had people being
like so you admit it and like you'd
think they're joking but there's like
long-winded responses there people like
we see you and we know who you're
working with and stuff like that and I'm
like these people think that was real
like they think I'm being serious when
whatever man there's only so much I can
do you know well and sarcasm is lost on
both sides to be honest but more so on
the left for sure in text that's a big
problem with modern cultures people are
trying to use text to tell sarcastic
jokes and the con the con it's not there
there's no contact yeah a lot of people
take themselves too seriously as well
seriously yeah I've got a I got uh
someone said that this it's the show is
staged I got here a script that uh oh
yeah there we go another copy of that
yeah this was uh uh delivered by Jack
besobic himself we filmed it uh he's on
camera delivering this in a little wagon
and uh then we read the lines let's
let's let's jump to this uh story this
is totally different story we'll take
talk about something else for once New
York Post reports Florida Yanks two
billion dollars from woke BlackRock over
social engineering project
crazy Florida said Thursday that has
begun to divest two billion dollars in
funds overseen by BlackRock a sharp
rebuke of the giant asset managers
investing policies under CEO Larry Larry
Fink that right-leaning critics have
blasted as woke capitalism the
divestment under DeSantis the largest of
its kind by an individual state is the
latest sign of mounting unrest among
Republican policy makers over so-called
ESG
what do you guys think DeSantis is
running good news victory in the culture
I hope he does because who else is there
Donald Trump and Kanye West I mean you
guys got to prove yourself to me if you
either one of you guys wants to be
president because DeSantis is leading
the charge let me just say this I'm
prime time I'm a pimp on a blimp I was
at Mar-A-Lago I was uh you know lucky
enough to be there because you know I'm
Prime on the ground all the time but
yeah The Vibes were a little weird in
the sense that like you know it was kind
of like the graveyard of 2020 so it was
kind of sad you know and everybody's
grasping for that energy of 2016 and it
just wasn't necessarily there and I
remember this is what Trump would always
say it would always say before he ran
he'd be like I can just be it more I
suck at impersonations but he'd just be
like I could just be at Mar-A-Lago you
know with my beautiful wife Melania and
I don't need any of this and he said
that again and the second time he said
that in the speech I felt it I'm like
dude you don't need this again you know
I understand that you were robbed and
that's how you feel and that's why you
want to you know come back but in the
Vengeance story will be epic and I hope
that if he runs I hope he wins
personally but I'm just saying it's like
why why do that when you just anything
any outcome in my personal opinion when
you're his age I believe he's 78 years
old yeah yep
on vacation Bud go to DC is a hell hole
I was just there I mean it's built by
Freemason freaking child Predators Bill
Clinton type people I mean oh my gosh I
wouldn't I couldn't imagine the people
that live in Washington they have a
freaking you know humiliation fetish I
believe I hear they drink a lot
is the biggest party town in the country
you have to be on fentanyl it's so bad
now party is one way to put it oh and
did you say that I don't think it's
drinking culture in the country or in
the cities I was talking about but this
is how bad DC is I want to bring up this
point I don't know if you saw McPherson
Square which is 0.2 miles from the White
House Tent City yeah yeah saw that video
last night like what didn't he make
sense what do you think about thin City
I'm luxurious I don't know Tent City
divesting from BlackRock I mean we've
been complaining about BlackRock for a
while I think Ian was the first person
to bring it up that State Street
BlackRock and who's the other one
Vanguard oh yeah they they all have
pieces of other companies and each other
it's so nice it's so crazy it's
collectively they own like 19 of almost
every publicly traded company it's a
wild man and uh I I like this divestment
because I'm really concerned about Black
Stone I believe it's Black Stone buying
property it's one of black rocks it's
like a an offshoot I think black rock is
an offshoot of Black Stone it's one or
the other well that's the biggest
problem in society it's like there's no
middle class because nobody can afford
to buy a home because all the single
family homes are artificially inflated
by these companies like BlackRock that
have such big portfolios if the you know
real price of the property you had to
pay the cash price or couldn't get these
easy loans if they weren't able to
artificially inflate the value of these
homes in a single family home could be
affordable but it's not because of these
companies yes black black stone I'm help
me out in the chat if you know which one
of the two companies it is but what
they're doing is essentially buying
property and holding it hostage because
they can afford or the loss they'll
print more money if they need more money
to stay solvent they use investor funds
to say solvent and they just wait and
they'll put put on the market if you
can't afford it you can't afford it they
don't they don't even live in there
exactly that's no we shouldn't have yeah
we shouldn't have mega corpse owning
property yeah but the worst thing is
Bill Gates owns the most farmland and
he's not going to farm on it because of
uh climate change well he is and it's
going to be corn but to clarify he's the
largest individual owner of Farmland but
he doesn't own the most what about how
much land China owns them absolutely
what's the point of that I mean that
doesn't seem right thousands of acres in
Florida for experiments on monkeys did
you hear that I'm an animal lover no
that's terrible yeah it's tough there
was a that knurling story from Elon Musk
came out and and this is why in the
conservative side we're like oh Elon
Musk is our hero but he's literally a
transhumanist that wants to put a chip
in your brain so you can park your Tesla
potentially so I mean I mean come on
that seems and I'm not even hating on
you Elon good for you but it's just he's
not he's not exactly our hero I hope he
is I think you don't want to park your
Tesla with your brain and if I could
live forever uh uh you know would you if
you could right now if first you know
because you're a wealthy young man they
say oh you can live forever Tim but no
we're gonna plug into this can be your
Consciousness into this computer you're
gonna live forever being young until you
die is is is like sounds like a good
idea like having the body of a of a 24
year old but you'll still die when
you're 78 or whatever you know you don't
live forever living forever I was
watching this thing about living forever
and they and it was saying that if you
remained young you'd never want to die
it's only that when you get older you're
tired you start getting one more pain
and you're like okay I'm ready to go
this is too much for me but if you were
in a young body you'd be like no I'm
great you're here with Jared Kushner
just said that I mean Jared Kushner he's
gonna live forever he's taking care of
his health right now because he plans on
living forever imagine if women could
have babies until they were like 300 if
they just their system is just a lot of
babies yeah that'd be good for them for
the population regrowth if we need that
if we can expand you know fertility ages
and stuff which we probably can I forgot
why I brought up Tesla but it doesn't
matter because the point you made is a
lot better than the point Elon made you
said that he wants to put a chip in your
brain so you can park your Tesla which
is is more likely to be what really
happens whereas he was like if you're if
you're paralyzed and your your spine is
broken we can make you walk again and if
you're blind even if you've never seen
in your life we can stimulate the visual
cortex and it's like it sounds really
really awesome but in reality people are
going to get in they're gonna Park their
Teslas yeah he just announced yeah so go
ahead we have we have these devices in
our pockets that grant us access to the
summation of human knowledge and we use
them to look at pictures of cats and
argue with strangers and he wants to
make that time the reaction time of
operation as you know as quick as
possible because right now I think he
always talks about the milliseconds that
it is the reaction time but he wants to
make it so it's just you know
simultaneous thought action you know
transhuman you are a cyborg cyberkinetic
connected cyber kinetically connected to
your device well he just announced human
trials that are going to be get be uh
beginning in in a few months where
humans are going to be implanted with a
microchip inside of their head and he
even made a statement saying that I
could have one right now no one would
even know I got to make this point too
let me tell you this is the problem with
artificial intelligence even the biggest
telecommunication companies from a t to
Verizon they have uh programmers people
that try to work on this every day
artificial intelligence so that when you
call in let's say you want to talk to
customer service you talk to a robot
that tries to convince a human that it's
actually a robot and overwhelmingly
99.99999
10 percent people realize that they are
talking to a robot so they cannot even
artificially recreate a conversation
with a robot non-person so the idea that
we can just like artificially create
another human that's insane but they can
use algorithmic technology to basically
you know like use you know guessing you
know whatever you know simulated guess
exactly Elon said he's gonna get the
chip I think uh in that in that reveal
he's like yeah I'll be I think he was
indicating he'll be getting it and I
think he'll the first tweet it was from
it'll be Elon will be the first one that
tweets from his brand it'll say his
tweet and then he'll say you know it
says tweet from iPhone it'll say like
from iPhone or from it'll say from Elon
musk's brain and you know what the Tweet
will say the actual text uh yes hello
world oh that's a good one or a great
part or I'm rooting for brain I am death
because what is it I'm imagining he's on
stage and he's like he pulls his hair up
and shows you the scar and he says I
have a neural link chip implanted and
I'm going to show you how it works I
have here my phone it's connected and
and
he's gonna collapse damnities like I am
alive again
I was just saying it was going to sing
just brain and then he's going to
collapse dude's gonna be tweeting from
his brain look man the
I got self-driving Tesla and it makes
terrible mistakes I wouldn't take a
brain chip maybe in like 20 years but
even that I don't even know about that
well I don't want it I would never take
it tell me this another selfish plug so
I have a show coming out at the
beginning of the year on The Blaze and
uh the set is going to be a a blimp so
sorry Tim that this is relevant and so I
was thinking about calling it The Mother
blimp and saying that my mom's
Consciousness before she died was
transferred to a computer and then she
actually runs the blimp and then I'm
gonna talk to my dead mom on the show is
that too much
are you gonna have like a like a voice a
speaker talking to you yes yes of course
is it going to be like a a voice yes
type voice yeah is that too much is that
I mean I'm definitely watching okay good
you know Amazon's attempting to do that
to create to capture people duh you can
live with your grandmother forever
in a computer simulation yeah it does
they want to do this would I do it no I
mean it's like buying a picture frame of
your Mom you can look at like a digital
picture frame like I'm saying they want
to make a VR where you have some sort of
like you know spirit I don't know I mean
it would feel weird but it's like a sex
doll or something I wouldn't buy that
never have sex with that so would you do
brain link neural net would I do that
are you interested in it no I would not
no that's I think that's like and I'm
not even some super religious person but
that's like the transhumanist satanic
thing now as soon as you do that you die
if you're like just because oh we're
gonna go well I just I just think that's
like the last come on we we are
humans that have souls you know we're
not like you know we're we're a soul
that has a body we're not a we're not a
thumb that just happens to have a soul
we're a soul that happens to have a
thumb if that makes sense so again we
have some important thing inside of us
so as soon as we like neural connect it
we tap into it we lose it I feel like so
that's why it's important that we do die
and that's why I'm starting to believe
in almost reincarnation I know that
sounds weird but I feel like and to go
back to my mom rip I miss you so much
but I feel like I see her like she's
around like she's maybe reincarnated
sometimes like I feel her energy Ian
asked earlier if we were in a simulation
and uh I'm fine with that interpretation
but I feel like we I this conversation
with Sheamus before that simulation
Theory feels like rudimentary
Christianity or like very very
rudimentary religion in general where
it's like if if you're gonna come and
say that you think we live in a
constructed universe made by a higher
like uh form of life or something I'm
like sure but there have been people who
have been you know theorizing
hypothesizing and philosophy advising
upon that concept for thousands of years
we just didn't have computers so they
didn't call it a simulation they just
called it God who created the universe
with purpose and reason and created life
so I kind of feel like you know I agree
uh I don't I don't really follow any
organized religion but I do believe
there's a God I do believe in something
akin to a soul I don't know I kind of
feel like the reason I bring it up is
because of what you were saying and then
you asked about simulation it ties back
into how crazy the universe is and me
personally I understand probability I
understand math but you see what's been
going on in news and in the world and it
certainly just does not feel like we're
on this track of Randomness it certainly
I just want to make one more there's a
reason some of the most powerful people
in the world worship Molech and demonic
entities and try to summon them in it's
been documented that there's something
else beyond our physical existence that
is there energetically within uh
different dimensions that we can't
quantify and understand absolutely
because the most important people in our
world do do Play in that realm well
don't forget about Malik I want to go
back on it but I mean the idea that
everything came from nothing that's the
same as a tornado going through a
junkyard and creating a seven you know
47 on the other end it's just impossible
I mean it's just but you know that's why
I know you think scientifically you know
this and that I just well look you know
I'm not trying to dismiss what you're
saying I'm just saying to think about it
like the mechanisms of the universe and
the the organization of free energy is
just a component of the Creator yeah I
know and that's why I think there just
has to be a critter and I don't even
want to try to sound like a Bible banger
but they'll even tell you that like you
know if a trillion monkeys punched you
know on a trillion keyboards that they
would be able to write Shakespeare
that's not possible right so I think
Cassandra she was like have you ever
seen a monkey she's like they'll just
poop all over yeah I mean come on so
yeah I think it is possible in the
definition of the word but that doesn't
dismiss that there could be something
creating the order that we notice you
think it's possible that even if a
trillion monkeys were hitting a trillion
at a trillion times times a trillion
seconds you do think that they could
accidentally hit it and recreate
Shakespeare
a trillion is a lot that's what I'm
saying I'm talking a trillion you guys
actually think that a monkey hitting a
keyboard would even with an infant see
with an infinite amount of times I know
in my head even with an infinite
Infinity loop-de-loop they would never
no no I disagree you and I a million Tim
pools times a trillion could never
recreate Shakespeare I just I disagree
trillion times infinity a trillion maybe
but Infinity no because you're basically
what you're saying is that with an
infinite number of monkeys it's
completely Limitless the iterations of
which they're smashing the key that's
what they're going to tell you
mathematically yes yeah that's the case
the likelihood is so close to zero like
it's point zero zero zero zero zero zero
on and on but the logical percentage is
zero and yeah you would say like
realistically it's very unlikely that
that would happen I don't think it's an
accident I don't think that people
accidentally typed up reality as we know
it it seems like this twisting and
turning of gravity and of subatomic
particles is all like uh counter and
interrelated and when you look at the
cosmic microwave background radiation
from The Big Bang this web of energy
that's fluxing through planetoids
beating our hearts I it could be an
accident yeah
that always should you know and that
shows us as the center of the universe
and that's why I do I do believe we are
the center but listen this is what I'm
just saying one of the biggest lies that
I believe that is done on human mankind
right now is they want to make you think
that you're just some sort of cosmic
accident that came from The Big Bang so
that you're an atheist so that you don't
have any sort of you know moral
responsibility for your actions here on
Earth and that like your life doesn't
really matter because when your life
doesn't matter you're able to be
indoctrinated and whatever have you read
about near-death experiences I'm pretty
familiar with it yeah I was reading I
read a book where it was just like they
went around asking different people and
they found overwhelmingly
the overwhelming majority experience
very very similar things in very
different circumstances like they
experienced a giant ball of warmth and
love and this feeling of being pulled
towards it and then there are other
people who describe things that were
like seemingly random or nonsensical and
so they were like it seems like 80 of
the stories are are very very similar
whether they were in a hospital whether
they were in the street whether they
were in a car accident
the overall majority experience
something very very similar described it
in a very very similar way that there
was this like bright light ball of
energy before them that they were being
drawn towards that felt like warmth and
love it's the sun what's up it's
magnetic yo we live in a magnetic
universe and our souls are magnetic
magnetically derived at pieces of energy
and the Sun is yanking us towards it and
our bodies are anchoring it to the Earth
our bones
but when your bones aren't anchoring it
anymore man your Soul's free to roam
something weird is going on okay so what
are we gonna do about these chips I
gotta know Alex before we move on what
do you think is the purpose of humanity
I mean is there a purpose I for us I I
almost feel like we were just
entertainment for the Creator at this
point we're like the Jerry Springer
I was like oh my gosh look at this Alex
sign call you see a big booty latina and
it's gonna make people go insane I think
it's a sorting algorithm as a
rudimentary way to describe it you know
we talk about heaven and hell I was I
was looking at a comic uh it was a Far
Side comic and there was a cow standing
before two two Pathways and they both
went to the uh the grinder whatever
whatever it's called like the processing
plant and it was like Choose Wisely I
can't remember exactly what the comic
was and I started thinking about it and
I was like when you're when you're here
on Earth
the way we view it the way I was taught
it religiously is that it's like be good
and you can go to the kingdom of heaven
be bad and you'll suffer suffer for
eternity and then I've talked to people
who are like believe in simulation
Theory and then I was like to my more
secular friends think about like a
sorting algorithm don't think of it like
being deemed worthy think of it like
we're here on Earth and it's not so much
that you are good or bad it's are you
you're being sorted we don't want these
they go here we do want these they come
here and the idea is that you want to go
to the place where the Creator wants you
to be like you don't got to put the
emotion into I'm just saying it feels
like we're here on Earth with free will
to make decisions to live our life this
is just how I see things and then uh to
try and and do the best we can for
creation for the organization for uh
expansion of humanity all this all this
good the things that we've described is
generally good and then when we die our
soul is sorted into the good side like
okay this this soul on Earth they did
good we're sorting that into good this
one did bad we're sorting it to bed it's
just simple like there you go I would
say with the way that the universe and
nature with the way that they usually
work if there's demons which your
politicians believes that there's demons
out there there has to be Angels so I
think
there's a lot of different things that
we don't understand I don't think we're
supposed to understand it I think this
is a big test I think it's a big
Challenge and you gotta prove yourself
and all right entertain us all three
tips I think you should actually do it
for the members only I got two questions
members only and I don't mind doing it
which direction are we headed or Blue
Chips you could say blue no we should go
after moloch because that is what you
must be kind of ties The Alex Jones
stuff you know and that's one of the
things that he exposed was going to
the uh Bohemian Grove where you know he
was able to go in there and they do an
actual you know sacrifice of a you know
they use like an idol a fake baby and
they you know mock child sacrifice yes
two two molec which is a big light on
fire yeah and see that's what I talk
about too I talk about this and I don't
know if I said this last time but like
their plan the evil people that rule the
world just literally out of the Bible
not that they believe in the Bible these
are actually satanists like I actually
believe Barack Obama's a gay Muslim but
for neither here nor there I'm not here
to talk about that what I'm saying it
comes out of the Bible it's Genesis
chapter 11 verse 9. you flip that Tim
911 getting weird what is that that's
the story of the Tower of Babel in that
story
Nimrod is wants to build a kingdom to
you know wants to build the Tower to the
kingdom of heaven to kill God and God
makes everybody speak different
languages and they break up in different
tribes so they want to reverse engineer
that plan people like Hillary Clinton
the people that you know supposedly
drink the quote unquote you know blood
of whatever Audrina Chrome yeah we can't
say that I don't know if we can say that
but it's oxidized adrenaline okay
oxidized I don't know if that's true but
I don't know but this is this is quote
unquote in a video game Minecraft
version this is uh Call of Duty we're
talking about Call of Duty uh someone
should make that video game actually and
so it is the reverse engineer that's the
one world order and I do believe that to
be true because it doesn't make sense
like it's almost like they even talk
about it and I'm not even a Star Wars
person but they want one Galactic
Federation in Star Wars I saw some meme
about that and I'm not even a star I'm
just saying that's what they want they
all want us under one ruler it's
probably not gonna happen in our time
but it will happen one day but let's
like I guess secularize that idea there
are uh like like Hitler believed in the
occult there are world leaders who
believe these things it doesn't mean
those things are true if there is a
powerful individual who is doing
something you know trying to summon a
demon or you know doing weird sacrifices
or things or like you know Spirit
cooking whatever it doesn't mean any of
it's real in terms of magic it means
they think it is and they're doing
really messed up stuff right yeah
they're mimicking a sacrifice of a baby
is it but most people there are probably
just like there for the ride and then no
they're really scary
Marina Abramovich did and she was just
recently on a Microsoft video they had
to take her down I mean she does look up
her look at Marina abramovich's blood
cooking yes
Balenciaga also as well I mean they're
all tape yeah and why would these very
important people some of the most
powerful some of the most busiest people
in the world spend their times getting
away in a weekend getting naked in robes
chanting and cheering on and celebrating
the the burning Effigy of a small baby
did you see the Babylon B article ball
dist distances himself that's hilarious
yeah people think that moloch is giving
them power I'm sure probably yeah yeah
like you got to get Klaus Schwab and all
these people on here and then you gotta
ask themselves see like they like
Aleister Crowley and Aleister Crowley
students like gimmick where he would um
in New York City he would start
mimicking somebody's walk he'd like walk
all weird and then all of a sudden like
let's say someone in front of him was
walking weird and then all of a sudden
Aleister Crowley would fall and then the
guy would fall and then everybody
watching is like oh my gosh she's
Satanist he you know he channeled that
and really the guy was like in on the
gimmick and everybody was you know
totally you know Bamboozled and then
that like Aleister Crowley would go and
he would do a party trick quote unquote
where he'd get like he would smell
people's breath and have the nastiest
the person with the nastiest breath spit
in his mouth so like this is a person
that they worship Aleister Crowley like
that's the leader of these satanists so
that's like how sick these people are
that Hitler was even looking up to yeah
I love Aleister Crowley yeah what about
Rasputin was he involved in that kind of
stuff no Hitler was in a cultist a lot
of people don't know this and he was
also a part of a secret society I was at
the talmud society that he was a part of
uh but but Hitler used to do a lot of
weird crazy satanic occultist stuff that
a lot of people don't even know about so
yeah and I'll tell you no but I gotta
say this I actually got to get this for
uh uh
1299 you can send me your credit card
and you can join the Church of
Scientology L Ron Hubbard we're going to
get you on a dietetics program if you
want to go clear
um yeah that's what we call it yes are
you kidding sir don't insult the man you
don't like Dianetics Tim okay first of
all guys
Hubbard is our creator we as Xeno is our
Galactic Overlord we live for a billion
years if you're willing to sign the
billion year contract with the sea org
which I did one of the best agreements
I've ever been a part of it's a one-way
type deal but it's still really good for
them and uh yeah I know you guys can all
join so I just need your credit card and
need your mother's maiden name you
didn't know he was related to Tom Cruise
do you look like his own stuff down or
do you just come up with it a little bit
of both but I mean when you're a
Scientologist you're so clear you're
like Tom Cruise it's like Hey listen
everybody called Tom Cruise crazy when
he said oh don't take Pharmaceuticals
and now every anti-vaxxer is like oh
good he was right on the money and he
was right on the money welcome to
Scientology Leah Remini come back baby
question that you said it was a really
good deal for them like it was it was
like a perfectly like executed joke like
did you did you write that down in
advance or is this you just come up with
this stuff well we know that it's a good
deal for Scientology it's supposed to be
a good deal for them because they're
helping clear the planet yeah no but
that's what it's about it's about doing
a good deal for them
where can he send the credit card
information
you know I'm just gonna be
gonna be a first the road's a little
bumpy but once you get to my level ot7
where I'm almost clear I'm almost a pimp
on a real blam and guys I have secret
knowledge I got my new show uh Leah
Remini I'm gonna expose her so if you
guys want to join you can be a pimp on a
blimp too I bought dinetics I bought the
book uh yeah I know it's like you bought
it for me and he's joined and now he's
in and now we're gonna take over the
world so no but but seriously welcome
I was skating down Hollywood Boulevard
and they had the guys outside the
Scientology building and they waved to
me and he asked me if I knew what it was
and I said I've heard about it and he's
like oh what do you know and then I
explained like the Xenu the aliens he's
like where'd you hear that a cartoon and
I was like yeah and he goes do you get
all your facts from cartoons and I
laughed and I was like no and he's like
how about you come and I tell you what
it's really about and I was like okay
and I sat down he gave me the book and
he was like whatever your thoughts on
this are and I did like the e-meter test
thing like we like it didn't make sense
to me nothing happened it just didn't
work I don't know what he was trying to
do but then he was the book was 20 bucks
and he was like don't you think you
should know what the book says before
you criticize it and I was like you're
correct I'll I'll read it and then I
read the first chapter and I was just
like this is nonsense what yeah well you
know like I'm not going to pretend to be
an expert I read one chapter but it felt
like it was doing uh it was like
exploiting tourisms saying things that
feel like it makes sense and then trying
to give you a solution to something and
I I just felt like it was that's what he
did too he was like here's this wild
idea don't you want to buy the book
before you criticize my wild idea you're
like well guys this is the thing it's
like self-reflection and you know
basically you know they do it where they
put you on the cans where you're
basically just doing like intense
psychoanalysis that does make people
theoretically feel better but the
problems with Scientology is how they
excommunicate you if you leave the
church or say like your wife is still in
she's not allowed to talk to you you're
not allowed to see your kids and then on
top of that they're very predatory they
get young people and they'll get their
credit card information and the Church
of Scientology will get credit cards and
these people's uh name and buy books
with it so the evil stuff like that is
terrible other than that you know it's
probably not bad to do some self-help
and be in a group like there's probably
worse groups but those two things are
just disgusting and I think that's what
makes when you watch that stuff like
going clear and you watch those
documentaries about them those are the
two worst things they do they have this
excommunication thing where it's like if
you're if you were a part of the church
and you leave you're now an enemy you're
not just a nobody you're an actual
combatant against us let's go to super
chats if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the share with
your friends and become a member at
timcast.com we have the Green Room Green
Room episode 35 is up where it's the
entire behind the scenes mini
documentary about what happened that day
with yay if you're interested in seeing
what do you how he was talking and how
you know how is behaving or it was like
a lot of chill conversations and just
you know normal stuff that's up now but
uh we'll read your super chats just
political BS says don't you think that
video of the Chinese being led to
quarantine camps is horrifically similar
to the old videos of Jews being led to
the trains I saw that video on Twitter I
played it in my report today it's pretty
Eerie there's also a Detention Facility
that was burned down in one of the
provinces as well is it confirmed that
they were leading people to trains
because I didn't see trains it was buses
that bussed them to the quarantine camp
and again these quarantine camps are
absolutely atrocious they're horrible
there's not enough bathroom facilities
and people just essentially just live
like dogs get their own food if they're
lucky uh and this this bigger Revolution
happened because of what happened at
foxcom a lot of the workers there were
locked in there for multiple days
without proper food without proper
bathroom facilities were forced to live
there and then they oftentimes do live
there yeah yeah often not but but they
said that there was a coveted case in
there so they had to lock everyone down
prevented people from leaving and that's
not what started the protest the the
factory workers left but then the
factory the the foxcom Apple Factory
promised them a bonus if they would come
back then they did come back and then
they didn't give them the bonus and this
is what created the uprising and Foxconn
if you want to be upset with the danger
of Nazism look at people that are
bussing people into quarantine camps
right now if you want to have a real
conversation about totalitarianism and
and fascism let's look at what's
happening in China all right it's as
simple as this is once you start trading
your literal freedom for safety you end
up with neither so that's what happens
in China guys they're not gonna have
either Chris cases wonder if yay has
fallen into the crazy Canadian mind
control expert he did warn you to chill
or he would regret it
uh there's another in the same vein
salty Larry says that story about his
trainer threatening to drug him I'm
beginning to wonder if he did to get Psy
upped he laid a stink bomb with Trump
then Tim Cass and now Jones it's like a
planned demolition
some people have been super chatting and
commenting that it feels like Yay is
sabotaging elements of the right right
as Trump uh announces that's what they
say about me they say that for everybody
I'm not saying they probably say that
about you they say that I mean you know
that's just they're just looking at
something to complain about I don't
think that's the case if anything he
probably actually makes more people
based in reality even if they don't
agree with us more so I actually do
believe he brings more people to the
populist movement than uh you know like
let's say if it was freaking some weird
leftist celebrity ran if that makes
sense
all right cool uh cooler says it's
refresh refreshing refreshing and
frustrating how Ian seems to be the only
one who understands how a mental illness
works not an excuse but people need to
understand
I've I think I've went through a
firsthand kind of like it was like
marijuana-induced psychosis but it was
also I was making a lot of Internet
videos and watching my own eyes and
believing my own [ __ ] like when you
become
you know what you think you are you can
become anything and it can make you
really really crazy so I've been there I
know what it's like to have a thousand
people telling you your crate and then
going along with that ride and like
getting twisted and I want to be there
for people that might be experiencing
that because it was very lonely at the
time well and I gotta make this point
too and somebody you know forget this
guy that said it about me but it's like
you know a thousand people say something
good you only hear the one person that
says something bad that can drive you
insane too yeah so definitely you need
friends the key is Friends friendship
it's uh Lonely at the Top as they say
yeah you need people to tell you that
you're acting out of line and to be
there for you and listen Tim can't even
go to Olive Garden
which is a travesty because what do you
mean sticks well you're worried that
they might do something to your food not
out here
I don't think here out here okay so now
you can go to Olive Garden get unlimited
breadsticks I didn't know that so now
I'm less sympathetic to you Tim good for
you like when you go to us so it's it's
a mixed bag I go to a city and I'll hear
people say like yo what up big fan but
you don't hear you do hear the fu Tim
pool stuff too and uh people this is why
Trump uh eats fast food because he he
walks in and they see the burgers
already done and made they can't screw
with it you know so it's safer for them
so that's a harsh reality man are some
cities breadstick friendly in some
cities not breadstick friendly I'm not
gonna eat the glutens the starchy cars I
know but if you know it's your wedding
Olive Garden is good I do like Olive
Garden your last meals you're on death
row oh they they used to have the the
Olive Garden I used to go to a pesto
sauce they got rid of it I don't know if
the other ones I think they still have
pesto I believe it's so good the creamy
pesto sauce just give me the endless
pasta bowl and delicious no you know I
really do uh I would rather have like I
don't know just like a ribs or something
yeah but Diego the manager at the Olive
Garden on Technology Boulevard if you're
watching this
[ __ ] you dude she's
trouble taking some breadsticks home and
they're not trying to exclude me now I
can only order online unlimited and so
now I should be able to do in the car
and now Diego's like oh no don't deliver
to that they know my Forerunner and so
if you're watching this Diego I was so
chill with you dude at your daughters
quinceanera remember I bought her that
pinata
yeah I'm gonna clip this and email it to
him because he only does email all right
all right Tyler B says clearly yay is
purposefully destructing
self-destructing to ruin his brand most
likely to get back as handlers who
threaten to lock him up and Drug him
they were greedy and the only way out is
scorched Earth
maybe uh there are a lot of people who
got rich off of yay right
and this is true for anybody
when you're getting big there are people
around you that'll like work with you
that'll do business dealings with you
because you don't do it by yourself you
work hard and then you know you'll get
someone who supplies you the materials
you'll get someone who does the
production get someone who's the
marketing yay imploding strips them of
their wealth and access as well but he's
got his money and his properties and his
bank accounts they may be freezing it
they may be taking it away but it's
possible I'm just saying entertain Tyler
B's comment that yay is like after
everything is said and done in the
self-destruction I have a hundred
million I'm set for life I'm gonna take
everyone down around me who screwed with
me but but really the the true story
here is what is Diego doing to to Alex
Stein I mean Diego clearly this is the
more important bigger story here that we
need to focus on he's limiting I can't
even I can't
and
you know honestly listen I'll be I'll be
totally honest
my wife and Diego they have a history my
wife and Diego Diego was my wife's
boyfriend for a little bit until this
whole Fiasco happened and then I went up
to their work and I almost got him I
tried to talk to the corporate office
it's a long story I'll just say this
much you guys better let me get my
freaking bread sticks or else we're
gonna have freaking issues and I'm on
the biggest podcast on YouTube and I
know you're watching this that's not
true and yes it is true Tim shut your
mouth and this is true in Olive Garden
this is the biggest ever and I'm going
to Tweet this at you and you allow me to
eat breakfast I'm sick of going to
freaking rock wall 75 miles away from my
house because of Diego and my wife
having an affair behind my back I've
been very cool about it Olive Garden so
let me go back not cool Diego not cool
man so yeah the criminal trespass
warning lift it now all of this one's
interesting uh Team d-a-t-l says Ian yay
said after the Laura Loomer phone call
his misstep was singling out a group of
people when it's the devil and the banks
I think Alex showed him the context he
needed with Jews is that today you talk
with Laura yeah she called and he put
her phone up but then afterwards they
continued saying the same kind of wild
stuff they did it is a problem
if there's a couple all of people of any
kind that are conspiring to destroy your
bank and your make your life a living
hell if that's real that's a huge issue
well I mean Carlin himself said like
it's one of his early Clips I think it
was in the mid 2000s when it's late
George Carlin so they don't they have
the same interests they don't need to
have a meeting they don't need to have a
cabal or like a legitimate conspiracy
they have all the same you know Etc et
cetera they have the same um they go to
the same schools they wanted the same
doctors Etc et cetera there's no need
for an actual meeting and an actual like
formal conspiracy they already have the
same interests their vested interests
they already have the same things going
for them and I don't think they have to
all be Jewish I don't think that's I
think that's a totally wrong thing to
look at it I think it's a big mistake
Tradesman says hey guys I wanted to drop
in and try to encourage you I've seen an
absurd amount of trolling on your vids
lately remember the guys yelling will be
heard first but us quiet fans still
support you you know I really do
appreciate it and I'll point out too
that uh we distribute the show more ways
than just YouTube and it's really
obvious when it's a troll campaign like
you get fake emails you get fake
comments because they only do it in one
place and so it's like hey that's weird
we distributed the show in this manner
and 98 positive response but then on
YouTube there's something specific to
YouTube so whatever it is that we're
doing on the show it is not show wide it
is platform it is unique to a specific
platform so you know that that says
something to me if if like 80 percent of
the audience is like you know here's
what we disagree on here's what we agree
on and they're respectful and then you
go to one platform where you get like a
higher percentage of people concern
trolling it just it doesn't work it's
like guys like we can tell it's not
legitimate because it's not widespread
it's like isolated you know what I mean
yeah but I'm learning to just kind of
accept it I'm not anywhere near your
level Tim but I mean there's I have
trolls you know I would say almost
stalkers that everywhere I go they want
to troll me you know anytime I'm on a as
a guest in somebody else's podcast
they're always leaving negative content
or comments so it's like you know I
don't really care if it doesn't affect
my content I kind of like it in a weird
way but I guess at your level it might
it might just be annoying but but I kind
of like it kind of shows me that I'm
doing good and I said this earlier
before we you know started the podcast I
said you know it's better for someone to
be talking bad about you than to not be
talking about you at all you disagreed
that's where you know I think that is
the case so what I was saying is uh
we'll keep it a little light maybe I'll
talk a little bit about in the members
only show
I don't care about trolls you know I've
been troll I'd like I've done my share
of trolling back and I've been the
internet since I was a little kid you
know I think trolling's funny I think
people go in the chat and they're
posting weird jokes about me it's like I
laugh like there's a meme where my brain
is a blimp and there's a basket hanging
from my my head and my body's in it and
so it's like how does that it's funny
but the problem is the real challenge
about the negativity is when
people that uh childhood friends
who like the last thing you said was
love you buddy see you on the flip side
they decide to try and make money off
your name by piling on and and you know
people you consider to be good friends
making up rumors or lying about you
things like that because it's Cloud
chasing because it's it's the for
whatever reason you know there's that
video that I think we all retweeted
where the guy said the world is driven
by Envy and it was really interesting
because he said
that despite the fact that the world has
improved dramatically in that from you
know me and the Great Depression to
where I am now people are registering
more unhappiness it's it's not about
greed because life is better it's about
envy that they see someone else with
something and he's right and it's kind
of something that I've brought up before
too in a different way his his was
absolutely like explaining it better
than I ever could but I would often say
like you today
have better Dental Care than Rockefeller
did you know 100 years ago or whatever
that poor people in this country are
overweight that poor people have access
to clean water that your average
apartment is air conditioning and a a
refrigerator in it and those were luxury
items back in the day but people are
still unhappy it's not even a point that
I just came up with it was I think it
was um
uh uh what's his face who's that
comedian who is beating it on the phone
with those women
you know I'm talking about Louis CK yeah
Louis CK he said it's things are better
than ever but people are miserable yeah
like it's kind of crazy you know yeah
but that's also too because I believe
the ssris like I don't know how much
medical stuff we can say but I just
believe we have a pharmaceutical system
that people say you know what
um I'm a little depressed and then we
give people an SSRI that you know
actually you know increases the thoughts
of suicide so I don't know I think
there's a lot of reasons why we're so
depressed that like you can see a
housewife with a million dollar mansion
and a great husband with no stress and
just have some of the most depression so
I I do think there's like some uh you
know artificial influences that cause a
lot of the mass psychosis depression
that's happening we were talking about
this yesterday A lot of people are
drugged up and medicated more than a lot
of people would even expect and
understand to a very dangerous level by
a very bad industry
yeah yeah well I love the medical the
pharmaceutical industry you guys are so
great they're the best
all right let's grab one we got Raymond
g Stanley Jr he says IRL is the go-to
non-cult political show when yay said he
got what he wanted maybe he meant ballot
harvesting he'll learn
he has to be back if he's serious I
agree like here's what I think
someone someone tweeted in response to
hearing that yay was coming on the show
that he must be desperate and I'm like
yeah I I agree like we're not we're not
the biggest show we're not uh we're
decently sized I suppose I look at a
bunch of other shows that are always
bigger you know I just kind of you know
we do our thing
and he even mentioned pre-show he was
like I don't need to do these podcasts
you know it's no there's no point for me
and then he he literally said but
there's something I get out of him like
that right there so it was clear that he
was like don't need to be here don't
care it's a waste of my time ballad
harvesting was beneficial to me and then
he got up and left yeah yeah the
campaign he did it for to see if he
could boost his campaign I think that's
the whole point is to get more people to
join us yeah yeah 24. he didn't totally
destroy it and Alex yeah but but hold on
I think why that came we we before the
show said let's talk about the campaign
and they were like yes of course and
then the first thing he does is say
we're not talking like no and he changes
the subject then he gets him and walks
out like so I think he got what he
needed he learned something and then he
felt like he learned all he needed to
learn and he left but the you know
ballot harvesting alone ain't gonna win
the election you gotta I guess rally the
the entirety of the human race if you
want to win an election against the
military-industrial complex right now
yeah I I I I don't completely agree
I I think we've seen if uh the polling
showed Republicans with a massive Red
Wave and why didn't it happen because
likely voters as a polling metric make
no sense anymore because ballot
harvesting is the rule of the land
that's it so now you've got non-likely
voters voted and so all the polls about
who's likely to vote didn't make sense
and they're like how did that happen
it's because of valid armors how many
sites was it 39 States again 39 States
it's legal I think in and it used to be
hard to actually get mail-in ballots but
not because of covet now he's just oh no
big deal here you go you know so so pre
pre-covered with absentee ballots it was
hard to do about harvesting in this way
now you just had to register for one you
didn't just get it you didn't just get
one willy-nilly now people are uh people
are just getting them all over the place
like I'm pretty sure they were dead 12
years ago I'm seeing and not only that
uh I'm pretty sure people who work for I
could be wrong but I'm pretty sure
people who live in West Virginia who
moved from California got their vote
even though they changed their address
moved to Western Union registered
California sent their ballot to West
Virginia yeah that's just crazy man yeah
knowing that they were in West Virginia
yes all right what do we got
let's see [ __ ] DJ says ladies and
gentlemen this is grade a 100
uh put to copium Pure copium yeah it
says put though so um but I don't
understand why that is you know I will
say that people project everyone is so
adamant they know that everyone thinks
and feels the exact same same way they
do
uh an important lesson is they don't
people think and feel different things
you know uh
there are a lot of people that just want
to be famous and there are a lot of
people that don't want to be famous and
the people who want to be famous are
adamant that those who claim they don't
are lying yeah yeah because they assume
like no way if I want it so do you
you're lying and it's just like or like
being rich and things like that I know a
bunch of hard-working people who I
learned this list when I was young man I
was working backstage at this event was
hanging out this famous band and when
they were wrapping up I had like all
access as a staff and I was like I'm
gonna get some people backstage they're
gonna be so excited and so I went
outside and I was like hey you guys want
to hang out backstage and they're like
nah I'm cool and I was like what what do
you mean no like of course everybody
here wants and they're like nah we're
cool and I was like we're hanging out
with our friends we're drinking we don't
got time for this and I was like huh and
this was when I was like 18 and I was
like oh I thought everybody would want
to hang out backstage no it's not true
well I know you're Mr Cool temp pool but
I would think anybody that actually can
actually turn on that webcam and click
record you want some sort of Fame you
want enough Fame where you can have an
audience I mean I know you don't need to
be like freaking you know uh on NBC but
I think there is some sort of level of
wanting to have an audience and chasing
Fame that I think even you have a little
bit Tim maybe but a little I think the
reason for the success of this show is
is because of the inverse of that like
when I started doing this show I was
getting to the anti-famous famous show
well I I think people who want people
who like succeed because they want
something they want to work hard I think
there are people who want to be famous
and then find ways to get it but this
show started as a component of me with
like 10 000 viewers and just like waking
up and recording for 10 minutes and
being like wow this is cool I'm making a
living and then it just started to grow
and grow and grow I didn't come out and
be like I have to have a million subs or
anything I didn't think it was possible
like I'm not even kidding I was like
there there's no way like I will ever
get that point like the the the when I
had a hundred thousand Subs it was
thanks to Carl Benjamin he he he does he
hosts this video of mine he asked me to
do a video and then also I got a silver
play button and then I got to multiply
that by ten I didn't think it was
possible but I just kept doing my thing
you know I mean it wasn't it wasn't like
I wanted a bunch of people to listen
it's just the way it is for people out
there that do want to be famous you
gotta really really question is why do
you want to be famous keep that in mind
keep that at the Forefront because Fame
is a byproduct but if you do what you
believe in
then you will feel good and the people
that watch you aren't going to be
traitors if you just get famous just to
get famous the people in the crowd are
gonna know that you're a fraud you're
going to know that they don't know
you're a fraud and then you're going to
disrespect them like do what you believe
and first of all you worked so hard you
know and I'm not just trying to kiss
your butt though but I mean think about
how many times you stream five nights a
week and then just how many videos you
put out during the day so I think if
anybody did that put in that work ethic
it'd almost be impossible to be a
failure in my opinion so Kudos on that
but on Prime Time 99 I'm a pimp on a
blimp I want to be Famous Amos cookies I
want to be in every corner of every
store I want I'm Tucker Carlson's
biological son he will not claim me but
I want that known and I want TMZ
everybody looking into it so Fame bring
it I I don't have anything else I got
nothing please I'm a pip on a plan
related to Tom Cruise too well yeah
thank you no if it wasn't for uh Tom
Cruise and what he did to protect zenu I
wouldn't be here as well I'm gonna do
iron on a blimp one day that'll be fun
my set with starlink is going to be an
interior of a blimp and the windows is
going to be Drone footage so it's going
to look like we're floating that's cool
it's gonna be cool too Max Redick says
Tim I'm with you on building a new
culture as a Tim cast member but you
must fight back against those trying to
destroy you you have the influence to
help change this culture please push
back against Cedar Hassan Klein Etc I
don't know what they're saying about me
because
I don't know I don't care you know I
just don't I don't know what impact that
has
yeah I think Hassan needs to needs to
accept Sam Hyde's challenge that'd be
epic oh my gosh Hassan needs to fight
Sam Hyde he would never Sam Hyde would
crush him I will I will I will say this
uh why don't you have Sam Hyde on this
show we we were going to actually yeah I
don't wanna I I want to be careful
because we usually don't announce guests
because we don't want to right that
would be incredible yeah lovely human we
we uh we we we did have a scheduled a
scheduling conflict happened yeah and I
know he doesn't like to be political I
don't think he tries to kind of stay
away from that he does I want to say one
the Andy Kaufman character under under
his thumb there's one thing I can say
you know I don't like talking about Sam
cedar because I don't like giving bad
people attention right but I have to
stress that like I respect what Max is
saying and I understand why saying you
have to push back because I truly
believe that Sam Cedar is a genuinely
evil human being yeah and I'll tell you
why what he does is he doesn't just take
a photo of someone for a subject like
when you're making a thumbnail you want
the subject and you want them expressing
something relevant to the emotion of of
the thumbnail so if you say something
like Joe Biden slams so and so over this
policy or Joe Biden gets slammed you use
a photo that shows Joe Biden in that
particular moment preferably the moment
in question but if it's a new story
without photos you try and find a photo
of of of the individual in that context
what Sam does is he uses filters to make
people look sickly yeah and he uses
audio filters to manipulate how they
sound to try and win the arguments or to
trying to just manipulate the view of
these things so when he was doing the
review of our song he put it through
some weird filter to make it sound bad
and whenever he uses me in a thumbnail
he uses it's it's a very weird filter
that like puts pots on my face and like
sinks my eyes he uses photos from like
he uses clips from like three years ago
when I was much much fatter and like not
from the show in question and the and
that is like a level of depravity that
is I know it's evil yeah it's like yeah
well I remember I just watched like a
two-minute clip I don't ever watch Sam
Cedar and it was just a caller
complaining about uh JP Sears and then
in the clip he's like he sounded like he
didn't know JP series was basically like
you know rallied his troops to try to
cancel him he's like if you know this
comic go go get him make sure that any
club dates he's at you know just type in
Sam sheet or JP Sears he basically like
told his audience to make sure he gets
canceled on YouTube that's a bannable
offense that might pass the strikes like
I mean Shapiro look like an elf type in
Sam whatever Sam Cedar JP Sears or don't
and that's and then like YouTube has the
nerve to come to me and be like allow us
to suppress your content and promote
this garbage yeah well I don't know Sam
Cedar sucks but it's remarkable how we
can be called milk toast fence sitters
you know sometimes facetiously and often
derisively and then they prop up some of
the most violent evil people on YouTube
whose whole career is just sewing hate
and Discord well people don't realize
it's not really what you want or what I
won it's kind of what we all want and so
and it sucks it's I'm not talking about
communism but it's more that populist
mindset so they're always going to say
you're a fence at her because you're not
far enough right so you're never going
to be far enough one way it's weird too
because it's like
fence sitting but also getting really
angry and like supporting free speech
and voting for Trump or something like
that it's like you know it was a meme
from a few years ago I can understand
but you know whatever I don't care
people can call me whatever they want
you know
all right can we get a can we get a few
more um hybrid says Ian I feel the same
way about this being the apocalypse I'm
not one to religious but the Book of
Revelation sure is lining up right about
now just time travel yeah it does feel
like that like the global economy is
about to shake and shatter
um governments are are now questioning
their own relevance and wonder if
corporations should be in charge like
everything is up for grabs it feels like
maybe not everything but so much is
about to change or isn't in change right
now and we're part of that change
Buffalo Bill says Tim cast has staged
like WWF No Lie first of all Buffalo
Bill they changed it to WWE yeah and as
I mentioned already I have here a script
that Jack pesobic personally delivered
before the show so we all had our lines
yeah that's right jackposovic two hours
before the show gives us our lines
everything we're saying right now is
actually scripted we study them and
we're all so smart that we memorize 100
200 Page script a personal script uh and
then and then well I have the neural
link from Elon oh that's how you did it
that's how I do it you don't want to
know what Ian does and where he is
he puts his transponder I'm very
sensitive to criticism
all right persistence over resistance
says Tim who really funds timcast I know
you have money but I don't think you
have the money necessary to fund an
operation like timcast so who really
funds timcast same people who fund AJ uh
100 owned and operated by me and funded
by viewers like you that is a fact
there's no investors there's no patrons
I think we have like
uh a handful of people who give us 500
bucks a month because if you go to sign
up for timcast there's like an option to
give more to be to be a gift a large
amount of people give 25 and then most
people just give 10 bucks as memberships
and that's it that's uh uh that's that's
the only way we're funded and we use
multiple uh uh payment uh processors so
we can track all of it and like uh I
should say like we know who our
customers are and we have we email with
with members when they have issues and
this is the craziest thing I don't
understand why people can't believe it
they can't believe that this is all
organic
yeah don't ask me why I don't know yes
but but sorry so just one more thing on
this people are like
they they either accuse me of being
extremely arrogant but at the same time
are making the argument that I
single-handedly built up this company in
the revenue stream and all that which
must be impossible to do so I'm like
which is it did I accomplish something
that's crazy or am I arrogant and funded
by the feds well I'll just tell you my
my opinion you know I know there's
people that are we talked about it just
for a second you know like uh Adam
craigler and anomaly I'm not even you
know uh you know people that are
throwing shots at you and I've always
been a loyalist too because you've been
a loyalist loyalist to me and I think
that you're a stand-up guy and I think
that in their you know circumstances
that you've done nothing egregious so I
just think Tim that that's going to come
with the territory being the top guy on
YouTube and I know you don't like to
think of yourself as that but I just
think some people are gonna you know
come after you and that's just it is
what it is but I mean like I can think
of a handful of podcasts to get more
views even left his podcast get more
views yeah but it's not about that and
I'm just saying I I don't think it's a
you know a personal attack but there's
people that are are that have said stuff
about you and I think it's on unfair is
what I'm trying to say I appreciate it
man uh we'll we'll elaborate on the
members only show there's a lot to talk
about especially eating those chips so
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member at timcast.com for two
big reasons one we have the behind the
scenes it's called The Green Room it's
it's the show where our guests are just
kind of hanging out and talking to us
this one was a bit more elaborate
because we actually flew out to meet
with them as they traveled here and it's
23 minutes long so it's a mini
documentary where you know Chris and
Aaron are explaining how it went down
because they were with them they ate
food with them at matsutaki and then
we're gonna have this uh insane video
where Alex eats four one
so smash that like button you can follow
the show at timcastirl you can follow me
at timcast Alex you want to shout
anything out just Alex Stein 99 on
Twitter Primetime stand on Instagram if
you can't find me you ain't looking very
hard
Alex thank you so much for coming out
this was a Great Entertaining show my
YouTube channel is we are changed thank
you so much for the Tupac shirt this
brought me back a lot of memories
because about 10 years ago I was
interviewing David I could Occupy Wall
Street and there was a black guy behind
me in the video Someone clipped that
video and made a separate video and I
think it has millions or tens of moons
of views with the caption Tupac is alive
as Tupac was behind me so this brought
back a lot of memories and eight years
ago me and Mark Dice hit the Streets of
San Diego and we went out there and told
people that Tupac was alive that there
was a press conference and everyone was
like oh my God it's amazing I knew it
was true I believed it so that video is
also available on my YouTube channel
youtube.com we are change uh lots of
Goofs lots of gaffs Alex this was fun
thank you and I gotta say this you
mentioned Mark Dice Mark Dice made a
call to action video to follow me he's
the reason my channel blew up I'm at 299
subscribers go follow me on YouTube Alex
and Mark Dice thank you so much Mark
subscribe to Alex Stein on YouTube get
up 300 000 subscribers is tonight ladies
and gentlemen thank you Jesus of
Nazareth is dead and I don't like saying
this but Jesus is dead and the Christ
that embodied him that he allowed into
himself is still here with us and we use
Jesus in his life as a as a template for
what we can become people like Muhammad
for his people and George Washington was
willing to give up the power of God of
King on Earth we need to utilize what
they gave us and and create something
relevant to now with it and we can and
thank you for being here with us while
we're doing it what's up homie hey I
want to say thanks very much for this
Whitney Houston thing a big house music
fan I really appreciate that it's not
with the Houston that's what's the
strands thank you transition yes that's
a violation on YouTube oh okay trans
Whitney Houston pardon me Susan don't
don't access uh yeah thanks guys I'm at
surge.com pretty much everywhere you can
follow me again I want to thank Tim for
the opportunity to be here doing the
show it's gets better every day it's
wild all right everybody we will see you
all over at timcast.com thanks for
hanging out cheers